plum und bauwesen wir kommen damit zum
einzelplan 12 digitales und verkehr und
da wird wohl die nachfolgeregelung des 9
euro ticket das thema gewesen sein was
am meisten diskutiert wurde in letzter
zeit interessant ist dass besonders wenn
man sich den einzelplan 12 anschaut denn
da gibt es deutliche kürzungen bei der
förderung des schienenverkehrs
allerdings muss natürlich gesagt werden
dass dieser etat entwurf ausgearbeitet
wurde vor der einigung der koalitionäre
am wochenende eben innerhalb des
entlastungs paketes hier eine
nachfolgeregelung zu schaffen kollegen
frank schäffler fdp fraktion
und der bundesminister volker wissing
sollte eigentlich als erstes sprechen
aber steckt wohl im verkehr fest und
deswegen ist hier die rede reihenfolge
etwas durcheinander gekommen frank
schäffler spricht nun als erstes
meine lieben kolleginnen kollegen der
koalitionsausschuss hat am vergangenen
wochenende glaube ich gute arbeit
geleistet er hat nämlich für diesen
wichtigen
investition set a der ja ein volumen in
der summe von 35 milliarden euro hat
glaube ich sehr gute arbeit geleistet
500 millionen euro werden zusätzlich in
die schieneninfrastruktur
gesteckt das ist glaube ich eine gute
nachricht auch vor die bahn in
deutschland
aber das ist nicht alles sondern wir
haben auch über ein oder wir haben auch
vereinbart dass eine milliarde euro an
verpflichtungsermächtigung in den
verkehrsetat zusätzlich fließen und wir
haben deutlich gemacht dass
ein angebot an die länder ausgeht dass
wir ein nachfolgeprojekt für das 9 euro
ticket haben wollen das aber auf soliden
füßen und soliden
finanzierungsbedingungen stehen muss und
das bedeutet das die länder ebenfalls
dazu beitragen müssen das ist ein
nachfolgemodell für das 9 euro ticket
geben soll das wird sicherlich nicht
neun euro kosten aber es wird sicherlich
finanzierbar sein und ich glaube auch
das ist eine gute nachricht
doch eins ist auch klar wir können nicht
alles was in 16 jahren angela merkel an
investitionsmaßnahmen versäumt wurde
jetzt in wenigen jahren wieder
korrigieren
allein im bedarfsplan schiene sind in
den vergangen sind 2011
11 millionen voraus gab worden diese
unterfinanzierung in diesem bereich die
hat dazu geführt dass wir in vielen
bereichen heute der deutschen bahn diese
mängel erleben diese koalition hatte
dafür gesorgt dass die mittel auf zwei
milliarden erhöht werden und die 500
millionen kommen jetzt zusätzlich dazu
das ist ein riesenschritt nach vorne
aber wir haben als haushälter dafür
gesorgt dass wir auch ein ja wie soll
ich sagen eine art kassensturz benötigen
wir brauchen wieder realistische zahlen
denn die zahlen auf denen die
bedarfspläne zurzeit fußen sind auf dem
niveau des jahres 2005 10 und deshalb
haben wir großen wert darauf gelegt dass
wir aktualisierte zahlen bekommen
und diese zahlen die kamen heute und ich
finde diese zahlen erfordern einen neuen
realismus von uns
diese zahlen erfordern einen neuen
realismus vor uns denn sie führen dazu
dass die tatsächlichen bedarfspläne 65
milliarden euro höher sind in der summe
als ursprünglich veranschlagt
also dass beispielsweise
bundesfernstraßen bereich braucht man 40
milliarden mehr in den wasserstraßen
braucht man fünf milliarden mehr bei der
schiene braucht man 20 milliarden mehr
um den bedarfsplan tatsächlich
auszufinanzieren
318 milliarden euro kosten die
bedarfspläne wenn man sie tatsächlich
aus finanzieren will und wenn das in
unsere generation noch geschehen soll
dann glaube ich muss man mehr realismus
an den tag legen dann muss man
sicherlich auch nicht nur die inflation
der vergangenheit also 2021 von drei
prozent berücksichtigen sondern da muss
man die drohende inflation in diesem
jahr von 7 prozent und vielleicht im
nächsten jahr noch höher ebenfalls
berücksichtigen und deshalb glaube ich
muss ein neuer realismus eintreten der
dazu führt dass wir dinge auch kritisch
überprüfen auf die notwendigkeit ob
jedes prestige projekt tatsächlich der
bahn realisiert werden kann das stellt
sich glaube ich inzwischen
beispielsweise muss er aus meiner sicht
der deutschlandpakt angepasst werden wir
müssen die dinge
realistisch betrachten und nicht jede
schnellbahntrasse in deutschland
realisieren sondern wir müssen dafür
sorgen dass die funktionsfähigkeit der
bahn erhalten bleibt wir müssen die
brücken sanieren und wir müssen auch die
reihen vertiefung das zeigt die heutige
zeit wir müssen auch die reihen
vertiefung im mittelrhein und
niederrhein voranbringen das sind
wichtige
infrastrukturmaßnahmen die jetzt
notwendig sind also mehr realismus und
mehr investitionen in die infrastruktur
in deutschland das steht jetzt auf der
tagesordnung und das werden wir in den
kunden künftigen haushaltsberatungen
nach vorne stellen vielen dank
vielen dank kranke geschäft aber dass
für die fdp und der
bundesverkehrsminister hat es jetzt auch
geschafft ist jetzt hier auch im
plenarsaal wir gehen aber weiter in der
rednerliste wie vorgesehen das ist nun
nadine schön stellvertretende
fraktionsvorsitzende der union
das jetzt bei uns sind dass der
verkehrsminister im stau steht es
natürlich ein bisschen treppenwitz aber
schon das ist zu uns geschafft haben
in ihrem haus herr minister kommt dass
der ja vor dem v und das ist ja nicht
nur im alphabet so sondern auch in ihrem
ministerium bmtv sie haben das haus
extra umbenannt und ich dachte immer das
hatte eine bedeutung dass sie das
ungenannt haben ich dachte dass die das
digitale wird kritisiert ich dachte dass
d das steht für digitalen auf flucht und
wir haben lange gewartet wie dieser
digitale aufbruch aussehen wird acht
monate haben wir auf die digital
strategie der bundesregierung gewartet
die große strategie die von ihrem haus
vorgelegt wurde sie sollte im juni schon
kommen aber dann müssen wir müssen ein
bisschen besser machen dann warten wir
mal jetzt am letzten augusttag in
meseberg wurde sie vorgestellt
und die reaktionen deutschlandweit große
enttäuschung ich kenne kaum jemanden
eigentlich was er ihnen niemanden der
gesagt hat dass es eine gute strategie
ist überschaubarer ambitionen die
ministerien denken zu klein chaos statt
turbo richtig begeistern kann das papier
niemanden das war so die gängige kritik
die man nicht nur im netz sondern auch
in den medien bei den verbänden bei
fachleuten überall gelesen und gehört
hat und selbst die kühle
bundestagsfraktion ihr koalitionspartner
mit denen sie doch gemeinsam den
fortschritt gestalten worden hat eine
deftige pressemeldung abgesetzt dass
diese digital strategie nicht gut ist
und noch besser werden müsste und in der
tat der digital strategie fehlt einiges
nicht nur eine klare vision wo es denn
überhaupt hingehen soll mit der
digitalisierung in deutschland sondern
auch konkrete maßnahmen
zeitpläne verbindliche ziele nicht nur
mindestziele kennzahlen und auch einen
klaren plan wie man welche ziele
erreichen will und das ist kein wunder
dass aktuell 71 prozent der bürgerinnen
und bürger in keinem bereich mit der
digital politik der bundesregierung
zufrieden sind wir von der
unionsfraktion sind das auch nicht der
digitale aufbruch den man hätte erwarten
können oder abgeblasen
das t
sollte hier auch für bessere digitale
koordinierungs den endlich ein digital
minister worauf wir so lange gewartet
haben
stattdessen sind sie von monat zu monat
für weniger zuständig am anfang ist es
ja noch viele zuständigkeiten und alles
andere wird über den digital minister
koordiniert mittlerweile lesen wir in
der aufgabenbeschreibung vor allem
gemeinsame zuständigkeiten es gibt ein
nebeneinander statt miteinander
digitale koordinierung digitale
schwerpunktsetzung und digitale
priorisierung durch diesen minister
leider fehlanzeige
und das fatalste wir sprechen ja heute
über den haushalt auch das digitale
budget fehlt das digital kitschig sie
haben sie angekündigt im
koalitionsvertrag sollte das budget sei
mit dem sie die großen digital
politischen vorhaben anstoßen
koordinieren vernetzen besser machen
durchführen
20 21 hat sich die regierung gebildet 22
hatten was das budget nicht im haushalt
jetzt sprechen wir über den haushalt
2022 auch hier fehlt das budget 20 24
können wir dann hat das parlament sich
nicht noch anders entscheidet endlich
mit dem ersten digital budget der
bundesregierung
darf damit rechnen dass ist dann im jahr
zwei der position von vier im jahr 20 24
also das verstehe ich wirklich nicht
unser auftreten forschen
und deshalb das kann
und dass frauen eben paar steht für
digital strategie vermurt digital budget
vertagt und digitale zukunft verdoppelt
herr minister sie können das dem ist
wieder hinter das v steht
nadine schön war dass und aufgrund der
parteizugehörigkeit des ministers gehen
wir jetzt erst einmal weiter in der
rednerliste wie geplant so dass alle
fraktionen einmal sprechen bevor dann
der minister hier zu seinem einzelplan
reden wird
[Applaus]
der gelder präsident liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen zunächst einmal möchte ich
die situation nutzen um mich bedanken in
diesen unruhigen zeiten ist es den
parteien der ampel koalition gelungen
ein großes entlastungs paket zu schnüren
danke an alle die dafür ihren beitrag
geleistet haben das war enorm wichtig
wir haben damit gezeigt
wir haben damit gezeigt dass wir die
sorgen der menschen ernst nehmen und wir
haben gezeigt dass wir handlungsfähig
sind jetzt und heute und die koalition
wird auch in zukunft handlungsfähig sein
you never walk alone nun ist es auch uns
abgeordnete hier
super ernste lage große krise und dann
so eine reaktion passt nicht zu dem was
ich hier in der generaldebatte sagen
überhaupt
sind so gibt die oppositions performance
da stehen mir überhaupt nichts wie das
zu kommentieren aber hier einen ort zu
machen wenn wir als regierung versuchen
einer schweren als regierungsfraktion
ihr leid schweren lage darzustellen dass
wir zusammenstehen der gesellschaft das
zu ironisieren ist die völlig falsche
sie völlig vermessen
bis jetzt haben und es ist ja an uns
abbauen dieses entlastungspaket auch
hier umzusetzen und mit diesem paket
machen wir tatsächlich beides wir
entlasten und investieren wie entlassen
bei den fahrtkosten für den öpnv wir
investieren bei den mitteln für die
schienen wie entlasten durch ein
bundesweit einheitliches
nahverkehrsticket ich bin optimistisch
dass es uns gelingt noch mehr menschen
weg vom auto in den öpnv zu bringen
dafür alleine wir 1,5 milliarden euro
die hand zusammen stark bedeutet jetzt
dass sich auch die länder bewegen müssen
damit wir da zu einem ergebnis kommen
und diese entlastung bei den menschen
auch angekommen und wir investieren denn
wir wissen wenn wir unsere klimaziele
erreichen wollen müssen wir massiv in
die infrastruktur investieren deshalb
nehmen wir zusätzlich zum einzelplan
entwurf noch mal 1,5 milliarden euro in
die hand und indium ihnen die schiene zu
investieren ich bin optimistisch
gestimmt dass wir noch mehr menschen
dazu bringen auf den öpnv umzusteigen
wenn wir beides zu entlasten bei den
preisen und investieren in die
infrastruktur dann werden wir auch im
mobilitäts wende schaffen aber das ist
noch ein langer weg
und wir sehen auch dass wir erhebliche
probleme in unserer infrastruktur haben
das ist natürlich eine erhöhung des der
verkehrslast insgesamt geschuldet es ist
aber auch ausdruck mangelnder resilienz
mangelnder flexibilität in der
verkehrsinfrastruktur auch hier gilt
dass wir stetig und mit langen atem
investieren müssen ich möchte die
einbringung des haushalts in sachen
verkehr hier auch nutzen um auf ein paar
besondere herausforderungen hinzu beiden
denen wir uns in den kommenden monaten
und jahren widmen müssen erstens
wasserstraßen
wir werden in diesem haushalt und den
kommenden jahren nicht drum rum kommt
hier besser zu werden wir können es uns
nicht leisten in diesem bereich auf
verschleiß zu fahren zwei
besondere projekte
besondere projekte der infrastruktur von
nationaler bedeutung ich möchte hier die
köhlbrandt querung im hamburger hafen
nennen wir werden einen ersatzneubau als
tunnelbau dafür bedarf ist planungs und
finanzierungssicherheit damit dieses für
ganz deutschland wichtige projekt nicht
verzögert wird drittens das
digitale automatische kopplung in diesem
haushalt brauchen wir für die digitale
gucken noch keine höheren aufwendungen
aber jetzt wird das in den nächsten
jahren ganz anders sein es wird einen
europäischen und nationalen kraftakt
kraftakt brauchen um die digitale
kupplung in den kommenden jahren
einzuführen das wird auch erhebliche
finanzielle mittel brauche und viertens
weichen in den letzten 30 jahren sind
tausende weichen aus unserem china
entfernt worden der bahn chef spricht
von 70.000 weichen wie viel es ganz
genauso wissen wir nicht aber es sind
viele viele von diesen bereichen braucht
man nicht mehr entschieden jetzt bei
strecken stillgelegt wurden und andere
sind bau weichen die nur vorübergehend
genutzt worden die meisten weichen sind
allerdings aus einem anderen grund
entfernt worden aus kostengründen so
eine weiche kostet nämlich geld in der
anschaffung und im unterhalt
unter dem druck von privatisierungs
fantasien und der rein
betriebswirtschaftlichen betrachtung des
schienennetzes in den letzten
jahrzehnten unter diesem druck sind die
weichen ausgebaut wurden und das merken
wir jeden tag im netz den weichen machen
das netz rizzoli entgegen
unvorhergesehenes man kann züge mit
weichen um längen und alternative routen
nehmen gibt es keine passenden weiche
steht dazu etwa bei baustellen das meer
wie bei jeder verspätung indizien jetzt
jeden tag wir merken dass aber auch bei
den priorisierung von kohle transporten
in diesen tagen auf der schiene
personenzüge müssen jetzt auch deshalb
häufiger warten weil es keine
alternative streckenführung geht denn es
gibt nicht genug weichen und ganz
schlimm wird es bei den unfällen die
jüngst in hamburg auf der s bahn linie
die wir kolleginnen und kollegen damit
unser netz resilient wird brauchen wir
wieder mehr weichen im system ich freue
mich auf die haushaltsverhandlungen das
ist immer eine besonders intensive
interessante zeit lassen sie uns
gemeinsam die menschen unserem land
entlasten und in unsere infrastruktur
investieren vielen dank
metin hakverdi freut sich auf die
debatten der haushaltsausschuss hat hier
im bundestag ja auch ein recht großes
gewicht wenn er hier über die etats
verhandelt und auch der nächste redner
ist mitglied des haushaltsausschusses
markus bilke die afx die fraktion
herr präsident sehr geehrte damen und
herren der beraten heute den haushalt
für digitales und verkehr und damit den
größten investitionshaushalt des bundes
investitionshaushalt heißt investieren
und da fangen die probleme in ihrem
entwurf an herr minister wissing sie
gehen von ausgabe resten in diesem jahr
von 7,2 milliarden euro aus das ist der
absolute spitzenwert seit jahren 2,1
milliarden ausgaben reste
bundesschienenwege und über eine
milliarde euro bei digitale
infrastruktur investitionen auf dem
papier die nicht realisiert werden sind
augenwischerei und bringen 0 fortschritt
unsere infrastruktur ist stark belastet
also muss die substanzerhaltung auch
2023 im fokus stehen abertausende marode
brücken sprechen eine deutliche sprache
und zeigen wie groß die aufgaben bei der
sanierung der infrastruktur wirklich
sind unsere straßen wickeln fast 80
prozent des verkehrs ab und das muss ich
auch bei den investitionen in den erhalt
im haushaltsplan widerspiegeln aber bei
aller kritik an den normen ausgabe
resten und den nicht realisierten bzw
abgeschlossenen investitionen am meisten
interessiert die bürger wie sich die
preise an den tankstellen nach dem
kurzen tank rabatt weiterentwickeln was
für die autofahrer ein kleines sommer
strohfeuer war hat vor allem bei den
mineralölkonzernen für klingelnde kassen
gesorgt
herr minister für die pendler besonders
im ländlichen raum oder für das
transportgewerbe sind die spritpreise
unerträglich der hohe spritpreis ist
eine hauptursache für die hohe inflation
der das mühsam angesparte mit jeder
tankfüllung auffrisst der blick zu
unserem nachbarn polen zeigt dass es
auch billiger geht ein wesentlicher
unterschied zwischen polnischen und
deutschen kraftstoffpreisen ist der hohe
anteil an steuern abgaben beim deutschen
sprits denn es war und ist der
politische wille dieser und der
vorherigen koalition
autofahren zu verteuern und eine
ideologische verkehrswende zu betreiben
sei es durch die co2 bepreisung oder
durch hohe energie strom dass dieser
kurs fatale wirtschaftliche folgen haben
wird ist nun sicherlich allen bewusst
geworden andere machen mit ihr und
deutlich niedrigeren kraftstoffpreisen
vor wie es geht waren sie dauerhaft
schluss mit all den hohen abgaben und
bepreisung gehen sie runter mit den
renten steuern auf kraftstoff und hoch
mit der pendlerpauschale
handeln sie jetzt vielen dank
danke gefühlen
nächste rednerin ist die kollegen dr
paul dudley potter bündnis 90 die grünen
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter herr präsident lieber
zuschauern zuschauer liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen sie haben gerade so hämisch
geklatscht und gelacht bei der
unionsfraktion aber wenn man sich dieses
kabinett anschaut und sich fragt wer von
diesen ministerinnen und ministern hat
eigentlich das schwerste erbe angetreten
dann gibt es da ein geht die einem
einfallen und volker wissing ist
definitiv in der engeren auswahl weil
das was wir diesen spätsommer
das was mit diesen stets bei unserer
verkehrsinfrastruktur leben ist nicht
das ergebnis der letzten zwölf monate
verkehrspolitik wir erleben in diesem
spätsommer egal ob wir auf die schiene
schauen oder auch die wasserstraße oder
auch die straße wir erleben dass
angesichts der neuen realitäten die sind
jetzt schon da die neuen realitäten von
klimakrise steigenden energiepreisen
international prekäre lieferketten
fachkräftemangel liefermenge bei den
baustoffen etc dass angesichts dieser
punkte tatsächlich unsere
verkehrsinfrastruktur nicht robust genug
ist und nicht flexibel genug ist und
einfach nicht genug puffer hat um diese
zusätzlichen herausforderungen zu
stemmen und
verkehrspolitik funktioniert langfristig
und das ergebnis der letzten jahrzehnte
lassen sie mich es konkret machen wir
schauen auf die wasserstraße alle von
uns haben es gelesen historisch niedrige
wasserstände nicht nur um rein aber vor
allen dingen auch beim rhein das führt
dazu dass weniger transportiert werden
kann was auch daran liegt dass wir immer
noch zu wenige schiffe haben die da
niedrigwasser kompatibel sind und alles
das was da nicht transportiert werden
kann soll verlagert werden die
unternehmen die gerade versuchen es auf
die schiene zu verlagern
die merken in diesen tagen dass das ganz
oft nicht geht wir haben jeden tag fast
über 50 güterzüge die fahren könnten
wenn die kapazitäten da wären aber sie
können nicht fragen wir müssen politisch
welcher zuerst fährt und denn die
wasserstraße und die schiene sich
gegenseitig da die kapazitäten nicht
abnehmen können dann bleibt nur die
straße aber auch die straße ist kein
verkehrsträger mehr wo alles heile welt
ist wir haben bei der straße aktuell auf
der einen seite auch fachkräftemangel
sprit steigerungen erzählt er aber zur
ehrlichkeit gehört auch dazu der kollege
frank schäffler hat es gerade sehr
abstrakt und für die großen summen
gemacht aber mal ganz konkret 143 bei
halle bei uns um die ecke die leute vor
ort nehmen das als quasi baustopp weil
da die kosten so explodiert sind dass
man die ausschreibung jetzt neu
aufsetzen muss und der bund hier die
notbremse ziehen musste und ich glaube
die mitteldeutsche zeitung die es kein
zentralorgan der deutschen verkehrs
werden aber ich zitiere jetzt mal auch
mit dem beispiel 143 die zeit der großen
projekte in straßen könnte vorbei sein
weil sie bleibt es bei diesen preisen
einfach nicht finanzierbar sind das ist
realität und das ist nicht so tack die
mitteldeutsche zeitung in sachsen anhalt
wir haben inzwischen den stadionbereich
die bürgerinnen und bürger in diesem
land sich nicht mehr darauf verlassen
können pünktlich und zuverlässig von a
und b zu kommen von a nach b zu kommen
wir haben ein stadium erreicht wo
unternehmen in diesem land logistik was
immer die planbare größe war das ist für
die keine planbaren größe mehr das ist
ein täglich kopfschmerzen induzieren de
risiko prozess im unternehmen geworden
und das liegt daran das liegt daran dass
die letzten jahrzehnte nicht genutzt
worden um die aktuellen
herausforderungen anzugehen wenn wir uns
anschauen wie lang verkehrsprojekte
dauern es stimmt ja wenn wir heute was
entscheiden das ist in 16 in 20 jahren
teilweise erst fertig aber das bedeutet
dass das was wir heute planen wo wir
heute die prioritäten draufsetzen das
wird realisiert in der mitte des
jahrhunderts und muss funktionieren
unter den bedingungen der klimakrise
denn so schwer dass hier einige von
ihnen mögen verdauen können weil sie so
langfristig ist müssen wir in der
verkehrspolitik besonders drastisch die
konsequenzen der klimakrise jetzt schon
mitdenken und das ist bislang nicht
passiert
meine damen und herren
genau weil es so unglaublich wichtig ist
das zentrale projekt zentrale
investitionen für eine gelingende
mobilitäts wende jetzt nicht noch weiter
verzögert werden werden diese
haushaltsverhandlungen auch unter der
frage geführt werden welche prioritäten
muss man setzen angesichts von
baukostensteigerungen sich
verschärfenden krise et cetera und vor
dem hintergrund ist es unglaublich
hilfreich was der koalitionsausschuss am
wochenende gerade für diesen bereich mit
1 5 milliarden mehr für co2 arme
mobilität und mobilitäts wende
beschlossen hat das hilft uns enorm und
das ist eine enorme verbesserung
gegenüber dem entwurf den das kabinett
zuerst vorgelegt hat und auf der anderen
seite ist es auch unglaublich gut zu
sehen dass wir hier sehr verantwortlich
und sehr fair jetzt in die verhandlungen
als ampel mit den ländern gehen um eine
echte lasten verteilen der
anschlusslösung für das neue neurotiker
zu finden und vernetzte mobilität
bedeutet ja vom rufbus auf dem dorf bis
zur großen 9 sehr schnellen ece trasse
dass da vernetzte mobilitäts und
verkehrspolitik gemacht werden muss und
die braucht dann an der stelle auch
vernetzte haushalterische verantwortung
von bund von ländern und von kommunen
und da haben auch wir noch ein ganzes
stück zu gehen gemeinsam mit den ländern
und mit den kommunen aber das wird
notwendig sein um die mobilität in
diesem land krisenfest zuverlässig
planbar wieder zu machen für die
menschen im land für die unternehmen im
land angesichts verschärfen der krisen
unter den konsequenzen der klimakrise
vielen herzlich sagt
pollak ich hab da hat hier die 1,5
milliarden euro an gesprochen mit denen
sich der bund jahr an euro ticket
nachfolgeregelung beteiligen möchte
allerdings sollen die länder auch zur
finanzierung beitragen ob das die länder
machen wollen ist noch alles andere als
klar
herr präsident sehr geehrte damen und
herren die regierung hat es nicht
geschafft das auslaufen des neuen euro
tickets zu verhindern und eine direkte
nachfolge regelungen auf den weg zu
bringen das heißt sie die letzten monate
dazu abgeliefert haben ist einfach
nichts eine große chance wurde vertan
und
was sie jetzt vorlegen ist mut und
kraftlos mich ärgert der umgang mit
unseren anträgen und täglich wir haben
rechtzeitig im verkehrsausschuss im
bundestag anträge zur verlängerung des
neuen euro tickets gestellt um zeit für
eine durchdachte
nachfolgeregelung zu finden wir haben
zugleich vorschläge gemacht 1 1 eurotier
dann tag oder 30 euro ticket im monat
365 euro ticket im jahr ohne
ernstzunehmende debatte und ohne
begründung wurde das abgelehnt als das
neue euro ticket dann im sommer immer
populärer wurde forderten spd und grüne
auf einmal eine nachfolgeregelung die
grünen mit den nahezu deckungsgleichen
vorstellungen die sie im parlament
vorher abgelehnt hatten und die meine
partei bereits beantragt hatte die
grünen sind in der kunst der
öffentlichen inszenierung mutter also
unserer vorschläge ja bekanntlich
meistern liebe grüne er sind nicht in
der opposition ihr seid in der regierung
und der hätte die sommerzeit nutzen
können eure koalitionspartner von
unseren oder von mir aus auch von euren
guten vorschlägen zu überzeugen
das habt ihr offensichtlich nicht getan
der jetzt vorliegende kompromiss von 49
bis 69 euro ist zu teuer zu weit weg vom
neuen euro ticket und untergräbt der
erfolg 52 millionen verkaufte tickets
jeder zehnte hat das auto stehen lassen
1,8 millionen tonnen co2 wurden
eingespart und sie lassen einen solchen
elfmeter einfach liegen und schießen
lieber ein eigentor ich kann es nicht
verstehen
100 städte und kommunen in europa haben
bereits einen ticket freien öffentlichen
personennahverkehr darunter luxemburg
städte wie wien haben bereits seit
365 euro tickets seit jahren die
spanische regierung hat jetzt eine über
gewinn steuer beschlossen und mit den
zusätzlichen einnahmen die nutzung des
regionalverkehrs kostenfrei gestellt
bevor unsere regierung eine so einfache
regelung beschließt trägt wirtschafts
und klimaminister habeck wie wir weitere
25 rhetorische pirouetten und erklärt
unter sichtbaren schmerzen dass es
gerecht ist wenn die gestiegenen kosten
auf die mehrheit der bevölkerung
abgewälzt werden hier wäre doch mal eine
chance gewesen wirklich in klimaschutz
durchzusetzen und darüber hinaus noch
eine soziale um zu treiben
beste ideen von nutzern nicht sondern
setzt sie um wer will dass die menschen
vom auto auf den öffentlichen
personennahverkehr und in bahnen steigen
muss die ticket preise massiv senken bis
hin zum nulltarif und massiv in den
ausbau von öpnv augen bahn investieren
sie bitte zum stehen wird er ausreichend
hoch wieder einmal gerecht
soweit die kritik von bernd riexinger
linksfraktion und nun kommen wir zum
bundesminister volker wissing jetzt hier
zu seinem etat einzelplan zwei
kolleginnen und kollegen
verlässlichkeit vernunft verantwortung
fortschritt auf diese vier grundsätze
baut der entwurf für unseren haushalt 20
23 auf wir müssen zuverlässig für eine
moderne leistungsfähige und sichere
infrastruktur sorgen wir müssen
vernünftig die richtigen prioritäten in
der verkehrspolitik setzen wir müssen
unserer verantwortung gegenüber der
gesellschaft gerecht werden sei es beim
klimaschutz oder bei der mobilität wir
müssen die rahmenbedingungen so zu
setzen dass innovation und fortschritt
gefördert und nicht behindert werden und
trotz der herausfordernden
rahmenbedingungen investieren wir daher
auch im kommenden jahr verlässlich in
unsere infrastruktur in schienen brücken
strassen fußwege fahrradwege wasserwege
und natürlich in digitalen netzen
all das
all das sind die lebensadern einer
gesellschaft und basis für wachstum und
wohlstand und all das ist die grundlage
für eine attraktive klimafreundliche
mobilität der zukunft unser anspruch ist
dabei immer vernünftig und
verantwortungsvoll mit dem geld der
steuerzahlerinnen und steuerzahler
umzugehen und dabei lege ich großen wert
darauf dass wir uns nicht in
zukunftsszenarien verlieren sondern
konkrete verbesserungen erzielen für die
bürgerinnen und bürger für die umwelt
für das klima und damit für unsere
zukunft und die unserer kinder
wir haben das etwa mit dem neuen euro
ticket geschafft deshalb teilhabe
ermöglicht die menschen entlastet und
gleichzeitig klima und umwelt es hat den
öffentlichen personennahverkehr gestärkt
modernisiert digitalisiert nie war der
pnv so präsent wie in den vergangenen
drei monaten
und es hat gezeigt dass man durch ein
besseres tarifangebot binnen kürzester
zeit sehr viele bürgerinnen und bürger
zum umstieg bewegen kann
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ich bin
froh dass wir an dieses erfolgsprojekt
anknüpfen werden und unser aktuelles
entlastungspaket eine nachfolgeregelung
vorsieht wie genau die aussehen wird
werden wir mit den ländern besprechen
wir werden jetzt intensiv und sehr
schnell auf sie zugehen unser ziel ist
es spätestens zu beginn des jahres 20 23
ein neues ticket zu haben und zwar einst
attraktiv ist unkompliziert digital und
natürlich auch bezahlen klar ist aber
wir haben weitere verkehrsträger und
jeder deckt spezifischer mobilitäts und
transportbedürfnisse von gesellschaft
und wirtschaft ab die finanziellen
spielräume
sie sind begrenzt damit müssen wir
umgehen und klug abwägen und der
aktuelle haushaltsplan stellt uns vor
die herausforderung unsere begrenzten
mittel so einzusetzen dass damit der
bestmögliche nutzen für die menschen in
unserem land erreicht wird wir müssen
also schwerpunkte setzen priorisieren
und das haben wir getan unser fokus
liegt dabei vorrangig auf investitionen
in das schienennetz in die wasserwege
aber auch in straßen und brücken in all
die bereiche in die jahrzehntelang nicht
ausreichend investiert worden ist
und sie haben recht frau kollegin dick
butter ich habe ein schweres erbe
angetreten was die infrastruktur in der
bundesrepublik deutschland angeht und
die rahmen der talbrücke bei lüdenscheid
sie ist zeugnis für versäumnisse und die
auswirkungen die die menschen dort
abtragen müssen wir geben zeugnis für
vernachlässigte infrastruktur
die gravierende folge der sperrung
dieser brücke sollte eine warnung sein
wir dürfen nicht vergessen dass eine
funktionierende infrastruktur
unerlässlich ist für die sicherheit
unseres landes spätestens in zeiten des
ukraine krieges ist deutlich geworden
welche zentrale rolle unsere
infrastruktur hier spielt etwa wenn es
darum geht lieferketten aufrecht zu
erhalten um die wirtschaft am laufen zu
halten um lebensmittel verzehrt zeugung
und versorgung zu garantieren und im
bedarfsfall auch militärtransporter
durchführen zu können klar ist schwächen
in der infrastruktur stellen
sicherheitslücken für die bevölkerung
dar und diese schwächen dürfen gar nicht
erst entstehen wir dürfen unseren
industriestandort nicht riskieren weil
unsere infrastrukturen nicht mehr
geeignet sind transportwege zu sichern
und wir müssen menschen und wirtschaft
mobil halt nur deshalb bin ich auch sehr
dafür eine verlässliche infrastruktur
stärker in unserem grundgesetz zu
verankern im koalitionsausschuss haben
wir beschlossen für das kommende jahr
zusätzlich 500 millionen euro in die
schiene zu investieren das ist eine
richtige und wichtige entscheidung und
wir stellen eine milliarde euro an
verpflichtungsermächtigungen bereit und
weitere einsparungen von co2 emissionen
im verkehrsbereich zu ermöglichen denn
klar ist wir müssen bei allem was mir
jetzt unternehmen unsere ambitionierten
klimaschutzziele hinblick ball wenn wir
aber zum beispiel 18 jahre für den bau
einer eisenbahntrasse benötigen dann
müssen wir über eine verlagerung von
mehr verkehr auf die schiene gar nicht
erst reden und im bereich der
brückensanierung bei der bahn haben wir
hier in den vergangenen
hatten deshalb bereits einiges auf den
weg gebracht und daran knüpfen wir jetzt
an wir werden planungsverfahren weiter
beschleunigt wir setzen gerade für die
china aber auch in allen anderen
bereichen auf smarte maßnahmen diese
sind oftmals nicht nur günstiger sondern
obendrein auch noch wirkungsvoller
wir werden deshalb die digitalisierung
konsequent vorantreiben und frau
kollegin schön ich werde nicht den
fehler der vorgängerregierung machen von
flug taxis zu schwadronieren mit denen
wir uns morgens auf dem weg zur arbeit
grüßen sondern ich werde das aufarbeiten
was sie haben liegen lassen
erhielt er die zahl strategie haben wir
sehr viele konkrete schritte geschlossen
allesamt voraussetzungen dafür dass
deutschland in zukunft in der top liga
mitspielen kann die zukunft ist digital
und deshalb müssen auch wir muss unser
land digitaler werden liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen es ist unsere aufgabe der
nächsten generation eine infrastruktur
zu übergeben die er ein gutes und
sicheres leben ermöglicht eine
infrastruktur die neue chancen eröffnet
und jedem die möglichkeit bietet sich an
seine ideen frei zu entfalten und
gleichzeitig müssen wir die bürgerinnen
und bürger heute entlasten und zeigen
dass wir alles dafür tun dass unser land
durch diese schwierigen zeiten kommt
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir
investieren und modernisieren und uns
gleichzeitig nicht übernehmen das ist
ein schwieriger balanceakt herr
vorliegende haushaltsentwurf ist nicht
nur ein finanztableau er ist ein angebot
an die bürgerinnen und bürger für eine
digitale eine mobile kann
klimafreundliche zukunft
vielen dank
der bundesminister für digitales und
verkehr volker wissing
das hat hier von einem angebot
gesprochen und unter anderem natürlich
den ausbau der digitalen infrastruktur
erwähnt das ist ein besonders ein etat
punkt der besonders
[Applaus]
gestiegen ist fast verdreifacht wurde
thomas bach spricht jetzt für die union
drückt den 2 für das
bundesverkehrsministerium in der tat
eine größten investor haushalte unseres
bundes und gerade hier ist es besonders
wichtig dass wir langfristigkeit
verlässlichkeit planbarkeit und auch
eine nachhaltige finanzierung auch als
grundlage denken wie wir wissen gerade
bei ihrem ersten großen projekt ins gibt
doch gar nicht zuviel projekte von ihnen
wie sie haben sie aufgeben aufgebot was
ihre vorgänger letzten jahren gemacht
haben christen großprojekt war dieses 9
euro ticket in diesem bereich muss ich
jetzt offen sagen ist letztendlich auch
soviel spesen nichts bleibendes gewesen
wir haben nichts was hier auch
langfristig gesehen den menschen auch
zur ruhe kommt ohne frage ist ein euro
ticket war etwas was beliebt war es war
einfach es war deutschlandweit gültig es
war günstig in drei monaten haben
durchschnittlich über 30 million
menschen das neue ticket genutzt aber es
war eine unglaublich teure veranstaltung
25 milliarden euro so viel haben uns
diese drei monat kostet es ist eine
enorm hohe summe wenn man überlegt dass
das bundesgeld für investionen
verkehrsbereich 20 milliarden euro
jährlich ausmacht also zehn prozent nur
zehn prozent des jährige saß allein für
dieses eine marketing projekt ausgegeben
das ist nicht seriös meine sehr
verehrten dauern das ist nicht alles
fertig sein so gesehen auch die probleme
der menschen auch passiert und es hat
auch nicht viel gebracht
drei monate haben kein mehrwert
geschaffen das angebot ist vor ort nicht
besser geworden im gegenteil es ist
sogar zurück dass einige nächsten
monaten schlechter wird es wird euro auf
alle fälle aufgrund der höheren
energiepreise und viele unternehmen
stehen rücken an der wand und viele vor
ort sagen du bist die leistung verkürzen
weil wir einfach nicht mehr die
möglichkeit haben bis finanziell
darstellen auch hier fehlen die 25
milliarden euro auch hier ein
rückschritt ihres neun euro tickets
auch die zielgerade
eine ganz geringe zahl der nutzer ist
wirklich vom auto auf die bahn oder auf
den bus umgestiegen auch das hat leider
nicht viel gemacht und viele menschen
können dort einfach nichts angebot
nutzen weil sie einfach immer noch auf
das auto angewiesen sind deshalb dass
oftmals auch ein programm für die städte
die länder regionen sind die welt so
vielen anderen projekten ihrer regierung
leider wieder mal hinten raus gefallen
weil es ja dann ein wirklich attraktives
angebot schaffen sie auch nicht mit den
15 milliarden euro die sie hier jetzt am
wochenende pressen haben auch das wird
sicherlich nicht letzten wochen
funktionieren auch da haben wir leider
nicht viel was nachhaltig und
langfristig finanziert ist herr
wichtigen sorgen sie dafür dass wir den
ausbau investitionen in den öpnv
langfristig nachhaltig auch investiert
das auch hier verlässlichkeit für die
kommunen zu länder haben nur dann
schaffen und wirklich ein angebot ist
wirklich die wünschen auch nutzen nur so
durch verlässlichkeit sicherheit auch
unfähigkeit und auch die verbindungen
wird werden die menschen auch wirklich
vor ort weg geht vom auto und den öpnv
nutzen das ist es langfristig erfolg
sprechende modell das auch wirklich
funktionieren und man kann zweite säule
des leistungspakets war der tank aber
auch dazu möchte ich kurz wahrsagen 14
millionen menschen
fahren auto gefahren und auch in der das
thema tank rabatt nicht von allen immer
sehr positiven populär gesprochen wurde
es hat allerdings vor ort den menschen
etwas gebracht es hat eine reduktion
fortgebracht und obwohl der tank rabatt
eine wichtige säule waren und auch ist
die lage ist wird der klammen heim
wieder zurückgenommen und die autofahrer
hatten erfolg zur kasse gebeten energie
steuern mehr steuer co2 abgabe diesen
oft über zwei euro 10 euro 80 eine
vierköpfige familie muss voraussichtlich
zweieinhalb tausend euro mehr zahlen als
noch vor einem jahr eine enorme
steigerung der kraftstoffkosten das
schaffen viele familien gar nicht mehr
und sie lassen diese familien im regen
steht damit ist dass die lassen sie im
regen stehen und die menschen wird und
angewiesen sind bei den räumen sind hier
wieder diejenigen gingen in der irischen
technologieoffenheit auch damals wenig
von ihnen gehört auch da brauchen wir
ein starkes bekenntnis kreis-fdp dass
sie auch weiterhin technologiestandort
in deutschland weltweit die besten
antriebsenergien auch produziert er
brauche investitionen in den
verkehrsetat nur so kriegen wir
erwirtschaften nutzen auch
wirtschaftliches wachstum entsteht im
sommer residenz lieber wissen ich bin
daher maßlos enttäuscht was sie hier
vorgelegt hat ihre folgen haben
schrittweise den etat für den verkehrs
in version von knapp 13 milliarden euro
im jahr 2017 auf über 290 milliarden
euro im jahr 2001 zu groß gezogen und
sie waren in ihrem ersten jahr eine
milliarde euro weniger ausgaben das
heißt
17 prozent preissteigerungen h sind
waren sie eine reduktion ihres etats das
heißt es gibt einen ganz ganz starken
der steinbruch in ihrem etat sie werden
dafür sorgen dass die nächsten jahre
weniger investiert werden kann weniger
gebaut werden kann und die
infrastruktur
thorsten ihrer vor schluss vielen dank
für den hinweis ich glaube dass wir viel
regen wirklich mehr brauchen deshalb es
auch der die haushaltsdaten entstehen
natürlich geprägt die wasserstraßen
genannt aber andere themen wir brauchen
verlässliche
investionen die feldwege wissing
insofern kleinen rückschnitt kein
fortschritt herzlichen dank
thomas bareiß beklagt dass wir mehr
brauchen für digitales und verkehr laut
einzelplan vorlage gibt es allerdings 20
1,07 milliarden euro weniger für diesen
einzelplan dorothee martin spricht jetzt
für die spd fraktion sieht
verkehrspolitische sprecherin liebe
gäste währte kolleginnen kollegen
minister wissen und auch die ampel
kolleginnen kollegen haben schon ganz
viele wichtige punkte und aufgaben
skizziert ich möchte drei schwerpunkte
heute hervorheben erstens wurde schon
viel geredet zu recht das von der ampel
auf den weg gebrachten neuen euro ticket
das war ein voller erfolg
ursprünglicher als reine
entlastungsmaßnahmen für pendlerinnen
und pendler gedacht hat es sich als
echte chance für die zukunft des nahen
regionalverkehrs erwiesen auch nicht als
marketinggag ich finde das sehr zynisch
was sie sagen und der erfolg hat sich
auch für klima und für soziale teilhabe
gezeigt liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
wir wollen die 2020er jahre nutzen zu
einem aufbruch in der mobilitätspolitik
so steht es in unserem koalitionsvertrag
und das bundesweit gültige ticket das
wir fortführen wollen zu einem
allgemeinen preis von 49 euro
vergünstigt für 29 euro etwa für azubis
studierende oder senioren das wird
langfristig einen beitrag dazu leisten
um es noch mal ganz konkret zu sagen
dieses projekt der ampel ist ein game
changer in der verkehrspolitik
der bund der leiste dachte sein
finanziellen anteil und jetzt sind auch
die bundesländer gefragt übrigens auch
die bundesländer in denen cdu und csu
mitregieren wir sind gemeinsam in der
verantwortung dieses erfolgsprojekt auch
gemeinsam fortzusetzen
und wer diesen sommer das ticket genutzt
habt ich glaube das waren ja fast alle
der kommt ganz unkompliziert in
deutschland unterwegs sein aber es wird
eben auch deutlich wo wirklich
dringender handlungsbedarf besteht neben
der debatte um die ticketpreise nämlich
bei infrastruktur bei zügen oder auch
per personal und um es klar zu sagen was
nutzt kollege riexinger was nutzt ein
günstiges ticket allein wenn da muss nur
alle zwei stunden fährt wenn die
anschlüsse nicht vernetzt sind oder wenn
dateien angebot besteht wir brauchen den
flächendeckenden ausbau fließen wahl
ändert auf dem land so das wird sich
alle davon profitieren übrigens auch das
ist soziale gerechtigkeit
gesorgt ich habe die uhr angehalten
gestalten sie eine frage oder bemerkung
des kollegen riexinger das mache ich
gerne ja
bernd riexinger hat eine zwischenfrage
wir zugelassen haben was ich nicht
verstehe warum sie das gegeneinander
stellen also wir brauchen beides wir
brauchen ja auch eine ausbau des öpnv
und billigere ticketpreise und was ich
jetzt nicht mehr verstehen worum sie
unsere ganzen anträge auf eine erhöhung
der regionalisierungsmittel weil damit
war der ausbau des öpnv auf finanziert
abgelehnt haben sie lägen bei den
regionalisierungsmitteln eigentlich
nichts drauf im haushalt und das
verstehe ich dann überhaupt nicht also
das widerspricht praktisch ihrem ziel
den öpnv auszubauen und die
investitionen zu erhöhen
lieber herr ischinger ich hätte sie
wirklich sehr auch für ihre sachlichen
beiträge was sich aber bei ihnen und
auch generell bei den kollegen der
linken nicht verstehe ist wirklich die
sach fremdheit und dann auch das
ausblenden von wirklichen haushalts
realitäten wir können den euro auch
leider nur einmal ausgeben und deswegen
wünsche ich mir auch von ihm und von
ihren bundesländern dass sie sich daran
beteiligen
und natürlich müssen wir eine soziale
gerechtigkeit herstellen ich frage sie
aber auch wir sind jetzt ja auch bei
einem system wo wir sagen jeder kriegt
diesen ticketpreis oder die allermeisten
für 49 euro und zwar wichtig und das
unterscheidet uns von unseren modellen
wenn sie sagen jeder soll 350 euro
zahlen dass es für mich gerade nicht
sozial gerecht ich möchte da eine
abstufung haben um auch mehr
möglichkeiten zu haben gleichzeitig noch
in den bestand was zu sichern hohe
energiepreise und eben auch auszubauen
das ist dieser dreiklang der es uns
wichtig und das ist mir bei ihren
debatten wo sie es zu sehr auf die
ticketpreise fokussiert einfach zu kurz
und auch die haushaltsfragen die wir
beantworten müssen das haben sie einfach
nicht beliefert
ich darf frau präsidentin hat es eben
schon gesagt neben dem ticketpreis neben
dem ausbau jahr an die auch bei vielen
verkehrsunternehmen im moment die
situation dass abbestellungen von
busverkehren karte schülerverkehr dass
anstand heben von far preisen dass das
wirklich real ist und auch das müssen
wir verhindern
und ja auch dafür brauchen wir mehr
mittel mehr bundesmittel für den
nahverkehr und angebot zu erhalten aber
eben vor allem auch zu verbessern der
zweite große punkt und das hat dieser
sommer auch gezeigt kollegin fischotter
hat darauf hingewiesen wie wichtig auch
weitere investitionen in die gesamte
bandbreite der verkehrsinfrastruktur
sind und ich sage das auch weil die
leistungsfähigkeit und auch die
zuverlässigkeit auch darüber entscheidet
wie gut wir krisen mit auswirkungen auf
lieferketten oder auch energieversorgung
löst bekommen das gilt vor allem das
haben wir sehr deutlich gesehen für
unsere wasserstraßen nicht nur für den
rhein ich war am nord ostsee kanal mit
einigen kolleginnen gelingen und wir
dürfen die bedeutung des güterverkehrs
nicht unterschätzen und müssen daher
dafür sorgen dass wasser straßen kanäle
schleusen und unsere häfen
leistungsfähig bleiben
für uns als spd ist ja die schiene ist
der verkehrsträger der zukunft eine
weitere halbe milliarde euro für die
schiene wie am wochenende beschlossen
das ist ein ganz starkes signal das
brauchen wir auch wir brauchen mehr geld
für die schiene für bahnhöfe viel
kapazität für überholt reise führt die
digitalisierung denn so sorgen wir für
spürbare verbesserungen im personen und
güterverkehr dir bei den kunden den
konten direkt ankommen müssen und zum
schluss meine damen und herren
mobilität klappt das haben wir alle
gemerkt das ist weit mehr als nur von a
nach b zu kommen das heißt sicher zur
schule zu kommen zur arbeit im
sportverein das heißt auch die welt
entdecken das heißt auch dass die waren
im supermarkt ankommen müssen dass auch
die industrie durch mobilität am laufen
gehalten wird deswegen kann man sagen
mobilität hat für uns alle einen so
hohen stellenwert für die menschen in
deutschland aber auch vor allem für uns
als ampelkoalition vielen dank
soweit dorothea martin von der spd
fraktion ist arena ist der spanien der
verkehrspolitische sprecher der fraktion
[Applaus]
vielen dank präsidentin ja sehr geehrte
damen und herren sehr geehrter
verkehrsminister wir reden hier immer
über bahn investitionen und
interessantes noch mal zu sehen oder das
geld tatsächlich hinfließt herr wissing
vor einem halben jahr erklärten sie hier
das 79 4 milliarden euro in die schiene
investieren und im juni kaufte die
deutsche bahn dann ein
logistikunternehmen in den usa mit 1900
trucks im bundestag erzählen sie den
menschen hier immer das märchen von den
investitionen in die schiene und in
wirklichkeit fließt das geld in us
amerikanische lkw vorwiegend mit
dieselmotor das ist die realität
entweder sie erzählen hier die
unwahrheit oder ihr bahn vorstand zieht
sie gnadenlos über den tisch beides wäre
eigentlich untragbar und das heutige
problem in der politik ist vor allen
dingen die fehlende ehrlichkeit und das
sehen wir auch beim neuen euro ticket
das neue euro ticket hatten wirklichkeit
vielfach zur bahn chaos geführt und war
in vielen fällen eben gerade kein ersatz
für das auto und jetzt haben wir die
diskussion um das 49 oder 69 euro ticket
in summe komme da auf den betrag im jahr
von 6 bis 800 euro wenn man das mal
berechnet und das entspricht überhaupt
gar nicht der heutigen realität
wir haben heute schon eine flatrate für
die leute die bunten des bundesweit
öffentliche verkehrsmittel nutzen wollen
ist die bahncard 100 die können ja alle
kaufen sie liegt zwischen 4 und 7000
euro und wenn sie hier anbieten und
suggerieren dass sie für ein zehntel
dieses geldes mobilität in diesem land
in die garantieren wollen dann reden wir
hier über gigantische subventionen wie
vorwiegend den autofahrern in diesem
land aus der tasche gezogen werden das
ist die realität
und wir wollen keine
mobilitäts planwirtschaft im übrigen im
übrigen soll jedes bundesland vor ort
doch selber entscheiden und wie spnv
regeln umsetzen will und es soll auch
selber entscheiden wie sie den bietet
öpnv finanziert werden soll und da gibt
es ja durchaus lokale unterschiede in
berlin hat man es ja nicht so mit
sauberkeit und sicherheit dafür bietet
man gerne drogen umschlagplätze an u
bahnhöfen an zum beispiel am kottbusser
tor es gibt auch andere bundesländer
wollen die menschen einen sicheren und
sauberen pnv und da stehen wir auch
dahinter wir wollen das und auch mehr
pünktlichkeit und deshalb wollen wir
eine nicht bundeseinheitliche sondern
eine lokale regelung sowie das ja
eigentlich auch im grundgesetz geplant
ist das neue euro ticket löst auch nicht
die probleme der menschen die auf das
auto angewiesen sind viele menschen
können sich die fahrt zur arbeit bei
über 2 euro pro liter ihm einfach nicht
mehr leisten und erklärungen fall liegen
ja immer viele ein inflation corona
ukraine jetzt nenne ich ihnen aber mal
die kraftstoffpreise in unseren
nachbarländern in europa frankreich
italien und spanien kommen wir trotz der
gleichen krisen bei 1 euro 70 bis 1 euro
80 pro liter aus hören sie auf die
autofahrer in diesem land zu täuschen
über die ursache der kraftstoffpreise
senken sie die steuern und die
unsäglichen klima abgaben
und im übrigen
lassen wir sie da nicht von der angel
sie werden nicht kneifen können die afg
wird nämlich wieder einen antrag
einbringen zur deutlichen senkung der
spritpreis in diesem land damit die
menschen in diesem land auch wissen wer
für sie einsteht und wer ihn wirklich
die mobilität bezahlbar halten will
vielen dank
[Applaus]
für die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
hat nun stefan gelbhaar duisburg
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte damen und herren der
verkehrshaushalt stellt mit enormen
finanziellen investitionen die weichen
für die zukunft deswegen schauen wir
genau darauf was das verkehrs und
finanzministerium da mit dem
haushaltsentwurf vorschlagen im
koalitionsvertrag haben wir es eines der
kernprojekte dieser koalition vereinbart
die klimaziele von paris zu erreichen
daran müssen sich alle ressorts messen
lassen und natürlich auch der
verkehrsbereich
das ist inzwischen nicht mehr nur eine
politische frage sondern dank des
klimaschutzgesetzes übrigens auch eine
rechtliche da ist also ganz klar die
erwartung dass wir da rechtmäßiges
konsequentes handeln vorfinden
denn der verkehrssektor verziert die
klimaschutzziele seit jahren der
haushaltsentwurf der regierung ist an
dieser stelle zu schwach um daran etwas
zu ändern und deswegen brauchen wir ein
sofort ein schlagkräftiges klimaschutz
vorprogramm und das muss dann eben auch
ganz klar im haushalt verankert sein da
gibt es diverse baustellen um den
verkehr zu vermeiden zu verlagern zu
dekarbonisierung
am wochenende haben sich die
koalitionsfraktionen darauf verständigt
bus und bahntickets mit 1 5 milliarden
euro pro jahr zu fördern wenn die länder
in gleicher höhe mit ziehen das finde
ich gut denn die verkehrsminister ist
nun gefordert da die verhandlungen
aufzunehmen denn worum geht es ein
bundesweites günstiges ticket wird
autofahren vermeiden und auch massiv
verkürzten pendler werden ihm nicht mehr
die nächste tarifzone fahren um geld zu
sparen das hilft es stau zu vermeiden
und zwar überall
doch wir wissen attraktiver tickets
allein reiche nicht aus die koalition
hat im koalitionsvertrag deswegen
vereinbart erheblich mehr mittel in die
schiene als in die straße zu investieren
stattdessen steigen im haushaltsentwurf
der regierung nur die investitionen in
den straßenbau das geht so nicht hier
muss nachgebessert werden und da ist ein
wichtiger schritt jetzt durch den
koalitionsausschuss auch schon gegangen
worden die investitionen in die schiene
sollen um 500 millionen direkt und dann
noch einmal um eine milliarde
verpflichtungsermächtigung erhöht werden
damit
damit wird die kürzung des
regierungsentwurfs für die schiene
zurückgenommen und das auch das ist gut
so attraktive tickets und gute
infrastruktur auch das reicht noch nicht
ganz in koalition die im
koalitionsvertrag vereinbarte erhöhungen
der mitte für den regional- und den
nahverkehr
die vielen weiterhin ohne diese mittel
erhöhung drohen angebotskürzungen hier
sind verkehrsmittel finanzminister
gefragt nach über einem jahr endlich zu
einer befriedigenden lösung mit den
ländern zu kommen
zum radfahren radfahrer schützt das
klima und führt auch an den autos auch
im regierungsviertel vorbei das ist sehr
wichtig gewesen dafür brauchen wir aber
tausende kilometer sicherheit im ganzen
land wir brauchen rad und fußverkehr es
brücken die umwege verkürzen wir
brauchen rat boxen und fahrer parkhäuser
an den bahnhöfen kollege gelb gestatten
sie eine frage oder bemerkung des
kollegen riexinger
ich kündige allerdings auch gleich an
dass in dieser debatte dass die letzte
nachfragen von mir die zehn kollegen
richtiger ist auch während riexinger
also
nochmal mit einem versuch eine
zwischenfrage
macht das ja eigentlich gar nicht so oft
mit den nachfragen von der mars hat
heute mal gehäuft
ich würde jetzt schon interessieren bei
den doch etwas großen ankündigungen zum
klimaschutz dass wir doch eine benotung
des hauses hatten mit einem ungenügend
des expertenrates was die einhaltung der
klimaschutzziele im verkehr betrifft und
der expertenrat angesagt hat er befasst
sich gar nicht mehr mit den einzelnen
maßnahmen weil sie völlig ungenügend
sind insofern finde ich schon irgendwie
ein bisschen bedauernswert dass sie das
nicht als grüne kritisieren weil
offensichtlich bleibt da das haus
deutlich hinter den selbst gesteckten
klimaschutzziele zurück und wäre es
nicht gerade ihre aufgabe als grüne da
man ein bisschen näher nachzuhaken
eric singer ich weiß nicht welcher rede
sind gerade gelauscht haben ich habe das
gefühl dass ich nach dieser rede von der
fdp
wie bekomme ich meine reden seiten haben
deswegen finde ich den hinweis
interessant aber ich glaube ich war
einfach fort vielleicht ergibt sich dann
noch bis 1
[Applaus]
sie wollten weitere bausteine für den
klimaschutz haben dann die kante liegen
auf der hand autos müssen endlich
elektrisch fahren dafür braucht man eine
funktionierende infrastruktur vielleicht
kommt auch um miteinander ins geschäft
und dafür müssen wir aus dem plan des
planens endlich ins machen einsteigen
und zwar mutig wir können und müssen im
verkehrsbereich muss auch sparen es geht
ist nicht nur klima und umwelt schädlich
sondern reine geldverschwendung wenn man
unsinnige straßenbauprojekte wie etwa zb
noch umsetzt und diesen offenen konflikt
die haben wir nach koalitionen müssen
wir endlich ernsthaft bearbeiten
alle wissen wer straßen sät wird verkehr
ernten
also lassen sie uns fahrrad bus und bahn
sehen bestehende straßen wasserstraßen
erhalten autos teilen und unnötigen
verkehr vermeiden stichwort home office
dann wird auch die mobile ernte gut
nachhaltig und modern sein und dazu
gehört auch ein weiterer punkt nämlich
klimaschädliche subventionen abzubauen
auch das steht im koalitionsvertrag
auch das wird noch im haushaltsentwurf
seit jahrzehnten werden drastische
fehlanreize gesetzt die haushalt- und
klimabilanz des verkehrssektors belasten
dann müssen wir also ran denn nur so
kann denn wir dreifach sinnvoll erstens
wir verhindert unnötige schulden
zweitens wir geben das geld sozial
gerechter aus und drittens wir handeln
nicht weiter klimafeindliche und damit
erhöhen wir nichts weiter als unsere
täglich sinkenden chance unsere täglich
sinkende chance überhaupt noch den
pariser 1,5 grad fahrt einzuhalten und
das sind für mich für uns anspruch und
richtschnur für die kommenden
haushaltsberatungen unser wünschte allen
ein gutes gelingen
foto stefan gelbhaar ist für die grünen
ja ein bisschen hat erst angesprochen
die ampel volle koalitionäre nicht bei
allem in der verkehrspolitik bei einer
meinung was sagen die linken bernd
riexinger haben wir schon mehrfach
gehört jetzt bei anke domscheit-berg für
die linke am rednerpult
diese digital politische sprecherin
sehr geehrte präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen auf jedem fünfundzwanzigsten
quadratmeter in deutschland kann man
mangels punkt netz nicht meine whatsup
verschicken auf jedem zehnten
quadratmeter kann man das nur mit einem
von vier netzbetreibern und auch
2022 sorgt in rumänien 70 prozent
schneller als im deutschen internet
minister wies hinlegt und trotzdem eine
gigabit strategie vor die weiter auf den
markt setzt und eine digitale strategie
die mich ehrlich gesagt aus vielen
verschiedenen gründen schier verzweifeln
lässt sie beantwortet nicht einmal die
frage in welcher digitalen gesellschaft
wollen wir eigentlich leben
aber wie will man der kluge strategie
entwickeln wie wir dieses bild gar nicht
hat und wie wenn man sie umsetzen ohne
ein digital budget
und dann das verantwortung server das
weitergeht niemand hat eine nennenswerte
steuerungs rolle selbst schlüssel themen
wie digitale identitäten werden auf vier
verschiedene ministerien verteilt
machen sie mal alle dieses kopfkino vier
leute aus drei parteien haben einen
stift in der hand und versuchen das
lesbares zu schreiben wenn das
funktioniert in ihrem kopf haben sie ein
bild davon wie die ampel im moment
arbeitet alle wollen mitreden immer aber
wenn es schiefgeht wird keiner
verantwortung tragen
apropos mitreden wir beziehen die
zivilgesellschaft ein verspricht die
digitalstrategie die überraschung
komplett ohne beteiligung der
zivilgesellschaft entstand und wie will
die fortschritts koalition ihren eigenen
fortschritt messen im laufe der
legislatur mit schwammigen zielen die xy
sollen gestärkt verbessert oder
beschleunigt werden und ohne
erwähnenswerte meilensteine für 2023 und
24 dafür gibt es 250 mal ziele für das
ende der amtszeit dass es ehrlich gesagt
ganz schön feige mein fazit ohne dann
zeitliche visionen ohne klare
verantwortungen ohne sofort verfügbares
budget ohne sinnvoll und messbare ziele
und ohne alter strukturelle probleme zu
lösen wird die ampel bei der
digitalisierung genauso scheitern die
die gruppe und das will ich mir nicht
mal als oppositionspolitikerin auch nur
vorstellen vielen dank
anke domscheit berg war das für die
linke und jetzt hören wir aus den reihen
der sozialdemokraten mit den
abgeordneten falko mohrs er ist mitglied
im ausschuss für digitales und verkehr
verehrte frau präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten damen und herren abgebrochene
mobilfunkverbindung hängen die
videokonferenzen wir kennen das und wir
dürfen aber sagen diese regierung diese
koalition ist angetreten mit dem klaren
versprechen dass diese zustände die wir
alle leidvoll erfahren der vergangenheit
angehören das ist unsere die sage
und kollegin schönherr bareiß jetzt wird
ihr doch mal mit dem blick auf die
digital politische leistungsbilanz der
minister scheuer und dobrindt da muss
man vielleicht um auch so ein dem
bildchen zu bleiben
feststellen total verlaufen aber wie
immer das gefühl zu haben oder richtig
unterwegs das war genau die digital
politik von ihnen in den letzten jahren
in ihren geführten haus
wir haben hier für uns klar gesagt wir
wollen glasfaser als die technologie die
uns nach vorne bringt und zwar glasfaser
bis in die wohnung das ist der maßstab
den wir anstreben und wir haben uns
vorgenommen den neuesten
mobilfunkstandard flächendeckend im land
sowohl im ländlichen raum als auch in
den städten zu etablieren das ist das
ziel was wir mit der gigabit strategie
unterfüttern und sie haben deswegen in
diesem haushalt 1,46 milliarden euro
vorgesehen um den glasfaserausbau zu
fördern meine damen und herren und 296
millionen euro um mobilfunk voran zu
bringen und zwar nicht indem das ganze
in einer mobilfunkinfrastruktur
gesellschaft versichert sondern da wird
es wirklich bei der funkmasten vor ort
ankommen denn das ist der maßstab nicht
strukturen schaffen oder mobilfunkmasten
und daran messen werden
und dabei ist kalkar thermale klare
abgestimmte vorgehensweise es gibt auf
der einen seite den eigenen
wirtschaftlichen ausbau der völlig
irrsinnig steuergelder dort auszugeben
wo es eigenwirtschaftlich passiert weil
wir aber in den letzten jahren eben auch
leider immer wieder festgestellt haben
dass man sich ja von mir auf den markt
verlassen kann und auf zusage dass es
aber auch nicht überall funktioniert ist
doch klar dass wir genau diese förderung
brauchen um eben auf der grundlage dort
wo eben nichts geschieht den menschen
eine perspektive zu geben und wo wir das
machen das entscheiden wir nicht am
grünen tisch sondern in gemeinsamer
verantwortung mit den landkreis mit den
städten und den bundesländern vor ort
denn die wissen auch was notwendig ist
und so kommen wir auch voran mit dem
vorhaben glasfaser bis in die wohnung
mobilfunk auch im ländlichen raum zu
etablieren
und weil es aber eben auch nicht nur
eine frage der digitalen infrastruktur
sondern auch beispielsweise digitalen
souveränität unseres landes ist welche
fähigkeiten wir haben ist eines der
riesengroßen projekte was wir uns als
ampel regierung vorgenommen haben die
mikroelektronik mit über 4,26 milliarden
euro voranzutreiben
das ist eben ein teil auch von unserer
souveränität damit wir eben auch
hardware in unserem land herstellen
können wir das in der vergangenheit
nicht begriffen hatte hat es hoffentlich
nach dem furchtbaren angriffskrieg von
russland begriffen dass wir uns eben
nicht abhängig machen dürfen weder bei
energie noch bei technologischen
kernkompetenzen meine damen und herren
und deswegen ist mit der gigabit
strategie mit der finanzierung der
ausbauvorhaben mit einer klaren
fokussierung auf alternative verleger
methoden wo und herr minister wissen
hier werden bestimmt gemeinsam schauen
müssen wie wir die guten vorschläge
beispielsweise eines fonds und den
kommunen vor ort sicherheit zu geben
wenn sorge haben vor allen dingen
alternativen verleger methoden wo wir
eben die zugesagte standardisierung wo
ihr haus ja auch gesagt hat wenn es
ähnlich durch die branche passiert dann
muss es eben auch politisch gesetzt
werden damit eben alternative verleger
methoden und ziele schneller nach vorne
bringen das wird neben den
haushaltspolitischen schwerpunkten einer
der kern faktoren seien uns der ausbau
gelingt meine damen und herren wir
wollen eben nicht einfach nur irgendwie
unterwegs sein sondern auf dem richtigen
weg das ist unser ziel dass es unsere
zusage vielen herzlichen dank für
[Applaus]
die cdu/csu-fraktion hat nun die
kollegin franziska hofmann das
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrter herr minister wissen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
als die ampel im dezember die besetzung
der ministerien bekanntgab titelte
telefonica basecamp euphorisch volker
wissing digital münster deutschland war
elektrisiert und hoffte auf die digitale
zeitenwende gesagt haben sie aber weder
beim haushalt 22 noch heute irgendetwas
zum thema digitalisierung
und so wie sie mit zuständigkeiten und
kompetenzen ausgestattet sind und immer
weniger zuständig sind können sie auch
gar nichts voran bringen und können sie
auch vor allem gar nichts auf arbeiten
wie sie gesagt haben
wenn ich jetzt den haushaltsentwurf nach
digital themen durch gehe sehe ich
vollkommenes chaos keine stringenz und
ein einziges kuddelmuddel jedes ressort
macht ein bisschen was und es ist sogar
noch schlimmer vorher gebündelte
zuständigkeiten wie zum beispiel für die
digital labore verteilen sie auf alle
ressorts hier ist kein koch sichtbar und
sie sind schon gar nicht der chefkoch im
übrigen redet auch in dieser debatte
bisher keiner der
koalitionsabgeordneten von
digitalisierung es geht nur und digitale
infrastruktur um ihre aktivitäten im
digitalbereich mal zu illustrieren man
muss schon dreieinhalb monate durch
ihren kalender gehen um 28 termine mit
digital bezug zu finden inklusive
sommerfeste grußworte und gespräche mit
unserer kollegin nadine schön sie als
digitalen minister zu bezeichnen darüber
würde andrea nahles hier wieder singen
ich mach mir die welt wie sie mir
gefällt
schauen wir mal wer in ihrem einzelplan
im kapitel 12 04 führen sie die digitale
infrastruktur auf andere kapitel zum
thema digitales gibt es schon gar nicht
und die digitale infrastruktur erschöpft
sich in unterstützung digitaler
zukunftstechnologien und ihrer
infrastrukturellen voraussetzungen
auch im vorwort fokussieren sie sich in
der formulierung der ziele
ausschließlich auf mobilität und
digitale souveränität das reicht nicht
das soll also alles sein was von der
schaffung eines digitalen ministeriums
übrig geblieben ist kommen wir nun zur
umsetzung der nationalen digital politik
hierfür planen sie 1,5 millionen euro
ein paar kollegen gesteuerten sie eine
frage oder bemerkung des kollegen moors
nein vielen dank das
ist also das was die uns als digital
budget angekündigt haben für die weitere
entwicklung des digital budgets gilt bei
ihnen wenn du nicht mehr weiter weißt
bilde einen arbeitskreis und auf das
große digital budget können wir also
noch ewig warten das sollte ja oft die
digitalstrategie folgen die haben sie ja
jetzt gerade vorgestellt dazu fiel mir
ein spruch meiner großmutter ein wie
sagte immer erst die strümpfe dann die
schuhe und die strümpfe herr minister um
die es hier geht sind noch nicht mal
gestrickt um im bild zu bleiben die
wolle hängt noch am scharf sie malen ein
sie malen eindeutiges bild der zukunft
ohne konkrete ziele sie bleiben komplett
waage im gesundheitsbereich zum beispiel
freuen sie sich daran messen lassen dass
das pflegewesen durch die
digitalisierung und robotik eine
spürbare unterstützung und entlastung
erfährt dass sich die datenverfügbarkeit
bei der gesundheitsversorgung verbessert
hat zitat ende
diese ziele sind nicht konkret nicht
messbar und vor allem nicht ambitioniert
jedes haus konnte projekte benennen und
auch solche die schon ewig in der
pipeline und umsetzung sind es fehlt an
einer ganzheitlichen politischen
strategie und an einer vision
ihre digital strategie und die mangelnde
haushalterische umsetzung sind eine
einzige enttäuschung
zur fazit unser fazit ist wir sehen
nichts bei der bündelung nichts bei der
vereinheitlichung nichts bei controlling
und steuerung von digitalisierung und
finanzielle mittel in ihrem ministerium
sie sollten das ministerium umbenennen
und zwar wirklich wieder im ministerium
für verkehr und digital der
infrastruktur mir jetzt in ihrem haus
nämlich nicht erkennbar vielen dank
sagt franziska hoppermann für die
unionsfraktion ja und volker wissing der
hat ja gerade sozusagen in meseberg
seine
digitalstrategie beziehungsweise
digitalstrategie die neue dieser
bundesregierung vorgestellt die neue
weil die meisten ziele tatsächlich sind
gar nicht so neu aber deutschland hat ja
einiges nachzuholen wieja millionen
menschen auch während des home office in
der korona partie erlebt haben der
unionsfraktion reicht
wer hat den rückstand in der
digitalisierung und zwar durch alle
ressorts zu verantworten dass man doch
gerade sie
erspare ihnen jetzt mal eine digital
ziele aufzuführen die sie in 16 jahren
regierungszeit verbockt und verfehlt
haben das würde nämlich die vier minuten
komplett sprengen mit der digital
strategie haben wir jetzt jedenfalls
herausgestellt an welchen punkten wir
dringend aufholen müssen und dafür ist
es allerhöchste zeit deshalb ist es
schon ein bisschen putzig uns
ambitionslose ich kite vorzuwerfen es
wäre ja falsch wenn wir wieder
wolkenkuckucksheim versprechen würden
und dass am ende nicht rauskommt wir
müssen jetzt liefern und wir müssen vor
allen dingen das vertrauen der
bürgerinnen und bürger zurückgewinnen
die digitalstrategie
konkretisiert viele vorhaben aus dem
koalitionsvertrag und bringt sie auf den
weg zum beispiel klimaneutralen
rechenzentren
da ändert jetzt gerade das
bundesministerium für wirtschaft und
klimaschutz das energieeffizienzgesetz
oder den digitalen verbraucherschutz
dennoch dem bundesministerium für umwelt
und verbraucherschutz mit dem recht auf
reparatur und dem digitalen produkt pass
voranbringt oder das recht auf
verschlüsselung und damit eine klare
absage an die sogenannte chat kontrolle
und ich hoffe deshalb sehr dass sich die
bundesregierung auf eu ebene
mit der ablehnung der anlasslosen
überwachung von messenger diensten
durchsetzen kann
in der strategie es auch der leitgedanke
public canepa blick konsequent verankert
open source ist nicht nur eine
alternative zu großen außer europäischen
tech unternehmen sondern eine
investition in die nationale sicherheit
in gesamtgesellschaftliche resilienz und
in lokale software entwicklung dieser
ansatz muss nun in dem
beschaffungsprozessen und vor allem in
der verwaltung digitalisierung dauerhaft
durchgesetzt werden
bei einem online zugangs gesetz müssen
wir auf volle kraft voraus schalten dazu
gehört endlich die digitale identität zu
etablieren auch hier müssen wir fast bei
null anfangen nachdem der frühere
innenminister erst mal falsch abgebogen
und dann in der sackgasse gelandet ist
dabei haben wir mit dem neuen
personalausweis bereits seit 2010 also
seit zwölf jahren ein sicheres und
funktionsfähiges system nur kennt das
niemand und es wurde eben auch nicht
weiterentwickelt oder bekannt gemacht
weil man sich eben auf eine andere
lösung verstärkt hatte dafür müssten sie
hier eigentlich zu kreuze kriechen
es ist kein geheimnis dass wir uns als
grüne bundestagsfraktion ein stärkeres
bekenntnis gewünscht hätten wie wir die
immensen herausforderungen
digitalisierung und klimaschutz
ganzheitlich angehen wollen oder im
hinblick auf die zivilgesellschaft die
wir als partner auf augenhöhe stärker in
die politik gestaltung mit einbinden
worden aber das ist jetzt auch in der
digital strategie angeregt und das ist
auch richtig so
kommen wir zum haushalt das digital
budget wird kommen der souverän tag fand
ist bereits im letzten haushalt
finanziert wurden fürs nächste jahr sind
zehn millionen euro eingestellt und
anders als behauptet ist die strategie
mit weiteren mitteln unterlegt so werden
wir milliarden in den ausbau der
digitalen infrastruktur auf dem land
investieren und in halbleiter die
nachhaltig produziert werden müssen
weitere posten werden wir im
parlamentarischen verfahren beraten die
dass daten institut oder ebenfalls schon
im letzten haushalt verankerte zentrum
für digitale souveränität mit anderen
worten es tut sich was auch finanziell
wichtig ist die unterstützung von
wirtschaft wissenschaft und vor allem
von der zivilgesellschaft wir können
unsere ziele nur zusammen erreichen und
so gewinnen die auch wieder das
vertrauen der bürgerinnen und bürger und
soweit wir dann eine solide grundlage
haben können wir dann zukünftig auch
deutlich ambitionierter seinen kindern
das wort hat die abgeordnete johanna
cota für die fdp-fraktion und sich die
opfer auch für die aif dem ausschuss für
digitales
[Applaus]
präsidentin werte kollegen wie gut es um
die digitalisierung in deutschland steht
das konnten all die grundstückbesitzer
erst vor kurzem feststellen als sie
versuchten sich bei elster anzumelden um
den fragebogen für die neue grundsteuer
auszufüllen das ergebnis das programm
ging direkt in die knie und war nicht
mehr zu erreichen willkommen im
digitalen deutschlands 2020 22
willkommen im digitalen entwicklungsland
und das war nur die spitze der zumutung
die den bürgern abverlangt wird
deutschland ist nicht in der lage die
informationen die schon bei den
verschiedensten ämtern liegen so
zusammenzuführen dass die behörden
selbst die neue grundsteuer errechnen
können nein die bürger die sollen sich
die arbeit machen und alle informationen
zusammentragen damit der staat ihnen
mehr geld abpressen kann was für ein
unding meine damen und herren
und ja in der neuen digitalstrategie
wird viel versprochen diesmal sollen
erfolge messbar sein und jedes
ministerium durfte projekte beisteuern
wobei durfte da das falsche wort ist
denn freiwillig geschah das nicht im
gegenteil die ersten projekte die
minister wissen präsentiert wurden die
waren so unambitioniert die waren so
kraft und mutlos dass der minister die
ministerien eine runde nachsitzen
verordnet hat meine damen und herren
allein daran sieht man dass die mehrheit
dieser regierung immer noch nicht
begriffen hat wie sehr unser land
aufholen muss in deutschland
hatten ende 20 21 07 prozent aller band
bei anschlüsse glasfaser in südkorea
sind es 87 in spanien 79 prozent sogar
kolumbien und costa rica haben uns
mittlerweile überholt das online zumaß
gesetz sollte dafür sorgen dass unsere
verwaltung endlich digital wird
575 verwaltungsdienstleistungen sollten
bis ende 22 online verfügbar sein von
der kfz anmeldung bis zur anmeldung der
hochzeit und nun raten sie mal wie viele
tatsächlich bis ende des jahres
verfügbar sein werden 50 50 von 575
tolle sache meine damen und herren und
ihre lösung sie verlängern einfach die
frist das wird schon klappen irgendwann
seine angriffe kosten die deutsche
wirtschaft bis zu 200 milliarden euro im
jahr besonders bedroht sehen sich die
betreiber kritischer infrastrukturen wo
bleibt da die konkrete anzahl portals
auf liebe regierung die zeiten statt
dessen eine beharrliche aversion gegen
innovative technologien die block chain
fehlt mittlerweile komplett in ihrer
strategie eine schlüsseltechnologie die
sie völlig ignorieren dafür sprechen
sich von feministischer digital politik
was um gottes willen soll das sein meine
damen und herren
das sind fast ein jahr an der regierung
und sie haben es noch nicht einmal
geschafft ein digital budget vorzulegen
die haben es gehört diese versäumnisse
kommen davon wenn man die
zuständigkeiten nicht an einer stelle
bündelt und nicht einer die
verantwortung trägt sondern sie auf
viele verschiedene ministerien verteilt
während die leidenschaft fürs digitale
fehlt die aber alle an die kohle wollen
wobei diese zersplitterung doch einen
vorteil hat und zwar für minister wissen
denn wenn das wieder nicht klappt dann
kann er all die verantwortung von sich
schieben und sagen die ministerien sind
schuld das ist fast so praktisch wie die
gedächtnislücken von olaf scholz meine
damen und herren
weniger praktisch ist jetzt auch eine
innenministerin zu haben die bei der
digitalisierung mitreden darf aber davon
keine ahnung hat so fordert der frau
feser in einem interview im falle eines
angriffs sogenannte heck becks und nur
um diesen wunsch ein paar wochen später
wieder einzustampfen und das gegenteil
zu fordern zuerst begrüßte sie die
initiative zur chat kontrolle durch die
eu dann lädt diese sie ab allerdings
noch nicht so ganz also was dabei
rauskommt da bin ich wirklich gespannt
und vor allen dingen bin ich gespannt
wie die fdp darauf reagieren wird nach
sondervermögen impfpflicht netz tg und
dem neuen infektionsschutzgesetz aller
lauterbach gehe ich davon aus dass
diejenigen die die freiheit für
ministerposten verraten haben auch hier
umkippen werden meine damen und herren
die bisherige digitale performance der
ampel ist dürftig aber immerhin gibt es
jetzt dass er rezept mein absolutes
highlight dabei man kann das digitale
rezepte auch ausdrucken und damit zur
apotheke gehen weil das mit der app
vorne und hinten nicht klappt und damit
sind wir wieder beim anfang meiner rede
wir kommen in digitalen deutschland 20
22 willkommen in digitalen
entwicklungsland vielen dank
für die spd fraktion heute nun die
kollegin isabelle carré motori das wort
das mitglied im verkehrsausschuss
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
verehrte gäste liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
trotz angespannter haushaltslage bleibt
die ampel koalition auf kurs und treibt
die mobilitäts werdende voran unter dem
gesichtspunkt des klimaschutzes setzt
der verkehrshaushalt ergänzt durch den
klima und transformations- fonds
wichtige akzente wir unterstützen die
antriebs wende in allen bereichen allen
voran werden wir den ausbau der
ladeinfrastruktur vor allem mit dem
erklärten ziel der elektromobilität zum
durchbruch zu verhelfen
dafür steigern wir in diesem haushalt
die mittel für die mobilitäts und
kraftstoffstrategie deutlich zu antriebs
wende gehört auch dass die mittel für
die erforschung von alternativen
kraftstoffen und die mittel für die
elektrifizierung im schienenverkehr
erhöht werden wir steuern auch noch mal
deutlich die förderung für den kauf von
bussen mit alternativen antrieben auch
für den radverkehr stellen wir mehr geld
bereit als bisher ein weiteres wichtiges
instrument um vor allem in
ballungsräumen mehr emissionsfreie
mobilität zu ermöglichen
wir bemühen uns darum als stadt auch
weiterhin die richtigen anreize für eine
verkehrs- und antriebs wende zu setzen
wir bringen eine fortsetzung der
umweltprämie für den kauf von
elektroautos auf dem weg die es auch
menschen mit mittleren einkommen
ermöglicht ein elektroauto zu kaufen
mit blick auf die klimaschutzziele ist
es auch richtig dass wir die hybrid
förderung auf steuergelder nun
sukzessive beenden
deshalb werden wir uns auch im sinne der
richtigen anreize mit einer reform der
dienstwagenbesteuerung beschäftigen
müssen um auch diesen bereich konsistent
mit unseren klimazielen zu gestalten
gleichzeitig werden wir die
automobilindustrie bei der notwendigen
transformation zielgerichtet
unterstützen
und wenn wir beim thema gute anreize
setzen für die verkehrswende sind wir
haben mit den neuen euro ticket einen
wahren durchbruch in der
mobilitätspolitik geschaffen und ich bin
mit dem dem verkehrsminister ehrlich
dankbar dass er diese idee damals
eingebracht und jetzt auch die
notwendige überzeugungsarbeit für das
nachfolge angebot geleistet hat
was wir mit dem neuen euro ticket
geschaffen haben ist eine wahrlich
disruptive innovationen im öpnv audi
übrigens mit der union niemals never
ever möglich gewesen wäre
durch die drastische preissenkung wurde
ein zusätzlicher anreiz zum umstieg auf
den öpnv geschaffen sehr viele
bürgerinnen und bürger die sonst niemals
öpnv auffahren haben tempora auto stehen
lassen dass nur ein euro ticket genutzt
für ausflüge für gelegenheits und
freizeitfahrten und auch in etwas
geringerem umfang für die fahrt zur
arbeit wir haben aber vielleicht auch
erlebt wie die infrastruktur an ihre
grenzen gestoßen ist wenn die
nutzerzahlen sprunghaft angestiegen sind
um eine apa klimarelevanten beitrag dazu
leisten muss diese attraktiver sein und
tatsächlich auch pendlerinnen und
pendlern zum umstieg zu bewegen und
deshalb ist es wichtig dass wir nicht
nur die preis debatte führen sondern
auch die investitions debatte in die
infrastruktur
es ist sozial gerecht dass wir die
positiven aspekte des nur 1 euro tickets
die einfach halten die bundesweite
gültigkeit weiterführen mit einem preis
der deutlich unter dem liegt das fast
alle menschen in deutschland für ein
monatsticket bezahlen und gleichzeitig
verstärkt in infrastruktur investieren
wir ermöglichen klimaneutralität für
deutlich weniger geld und investieren
dennoch kraftvoll in eine zukunftsfähige
infrastruktur
das ist eine gelungene verkehrswende
[Applaus]
für die cdu csu fraktion hat nun der
kollege felix schreiner
frau präsidentin meine lieben
kolleginnen und kollegen
wir diskutieren ein haushaltsentwurf in
bewegten zeiten wir finden jeden tag
aufs neue veränderte realitäten vor
inflation ukraine krieg steigender zins
das sind die realitäten mit denen auch
wir uns mit unserem einzelne tat zu
beschäftigen haben sie bedingen aber
auch ausdrücklich eine
schwerpunktsetzung die heute notwendig
ist und ich weiß nicht wie es ihnen geht
aber wenn man die rede und der
regierungsfraktion anhört hat man fast
den eindruck sie haben einen anderen
entwurf auf dem tisch liegen wie wir es
auf den tisch legen haben weil alles was
sie gesagt haben können wir faktisch
nicht in der kabinettsvorlage
feststellen aber herr gelb hat dazu ja
bereits einiges auch ausgeführt den wir
uns sogar anschließen könnten es ist
schlicht und ergreifend enttäuschend
dass der investiv haushalt verkehr in
diesen zeiten so drastisch gekürzt wird
es ist ernüchternd
das gleichermaßen für den klimaschutz im
verkehrssektor im klima- und
transformations- fonds eine kürzung
vorgesehen ist das hätten wir uns von
dieser ampel regierung nicht einmal
träumen lassen
herr minister wissing sie betonen immer
wieder dass der besondere fokus ihrer
regierung auf dem erhalt und der
sanierung der verkehrswege ist ja gut
das problem ist aber es steht nicht in
der vorlage ihrer zahlen sagen etwas
anders sie haben es versäumt die
finanzmittel für den erhalt und für die
modernisierung massiv aufzustocken
angesichts gestiegener baupreise findet
faktisch eine reale kürzung bei den
investitionen statt wir rechnen mit
steigenden rohstoffpreisen wir haben
eine steigenden werbe steigende
personalausgaben und wir finden dass
alles im haushalt schlichtweg nicht
abgebildet wir fordern sie daher auch
nutzen sie die parlamentarische beratung
die jetzt beginnt und korrigieren sie
diesen entwurf dieser regierung es ist
der schlechteste
regierungsentwurf die dieses haus je
gesehen hat
und wenn wir scheinbar konsens in diesem
haus haben dass wir in deutschland
schneller bauen genehmigen und vor allem
auch planen möchten dann frage ich mich
auch warum nutzen sie das nicht und
warum können wir nicht gemeinsam daran
arbeiten und sich diesem thema widmen
nein da steht nichts dazu sie haben eine
steuerungsgruppe sogar im
bundeskanzleramt eingerichtet die hat
bis heute noch nicht einmal eine
empfehlung vorgelegt wir haben hier als
unionsfraktion bereits im märz und im
mai konkrete vorschläge gemacht ganz
konkrete vorschläge liegen auf ihrem
tisch sie haben uns an ihrer seite aber
lassen sie uns doch gemeinsam zb an die
novellierung des bundesfernstraßengesetz
gehen an das allgemeine eisenbahngesetz
es ist das schönste in meiner
haushaltsrede weil es kostet alles kein
geld und wir können morgen sofort
umsetzen und werden endlich schneller
meine damen und herren
und wir haben sie auch schon gehört die
kürzungen im bereich der schiene sie
sind extrem und sie sind ernüchternd der
minister hat einen evaluations gutachten
selbst den auftrag gegeben um zb die von
uns noch initiierten trassenpreis
förderungen zu untersuchen die
kommission hat getagt sie kommt zum
ergebnis dass es eine gute sache war
dass die fortsetzung empfohlen wird was
macht diese regierung sie haben quasi
mit dem entwurf das ende und den
ausstieg aus der trassenpreis förderung
beschlossen ab 2023 bereits 2024 ist sie
halbiert ab 2025 vollständig gestrichen
meine damen und herren wenn sie wollen
dass wir ein marktanteil von bis 2030
auf 25 prozent anheben der muss doch der
schienengüterverkehr bei expandieren
gesamtmarkt von rund 60 prozent gestärkt
werden und er darf nicht geschwächt
werden so wie sie es heute vorgelegt
haben mit ihrem entwurf
und wir haben es bei der digitalisierung
gehört auch da fällt die schiene
komplett hinten runter aber ich muss
dann schon auch noch was zu ihrem billig
tickets sagen sie wurden von vielen
gewarnt sie würden wenn sie auf uns
nicht worden ist dass das eine aber wenn
sie auf ihre eigenen experten nicht
hören die haben ihn genau das vor gesagt
was jetzt kommt nach dem billig ticket
kommt jetzt die preisexplosion und es
sind doch vor allem die
familiengeführten unternehmen die massiv
unter den steigenden kosten unter
fehlenden refinanzierung leiden viele
busbetrieb busunternehmen in diesem land
stehen kurz vor der insolvenz sie haben
mehr als 50 prozent höhere energiekosten
als im vorjahreszeitraum
der fall war erste unternehmen drohen
bereits damit aus dem öpnv sich komplett
zurückzuziehen und was ist denn die
wahrheit wenn sie das bevor sie das
experiment billig ticket verlängern
müssen sie doch erst mal diejenigen
entlasten die jeden tag dafür sorgen
dass pendler zur arbeit gehen dass
schüler in die schule kommen aber wenn
sie diese betriebe nicht unterstützen
ist überhaupt keine power mehr da im
ländlichen raum stehen sie damit den
diskutierten 49 oder 69 euro im monat
wert wäre dazwischen dank
felix schreiner war es hier für die
unionsfraktion die jahr weniger geld für
die bundesschienenwege weniger geld für
die förderung des schienenverkehrs
verschiedentlich es schon angesprochen
worden hier in diesem haushaltsentwurf
in der debatte zu dem haushaltsentwurf
aber das ganze geht ja noch in die
parlamentarischen beratungen und
vielleicht wird er ja nochmal was
herumgeschoben bzw verändert robin mesa
roche für die sozialdemokraten jetzt so
wie wir heute pizza bestellen wir werden
windkrafträdern solaranlagen schneller
bauen können weil die anträge dann
digital sind und wir sind nicht mehr in
kleinwagen und kleinlastern von leitz
ordnern durch die gegend fahren müssen
wir werden das kindergeld ohne antrag
bekommen drei jahre später das angebot
von kindergartenplatz per sms so wird
deutschland eines tages sein die frage
ist nur wann ich sage es macht einen
riesenunterschied ob wir damit schnell
oder langsam sind sind wir zu langsam
verlieren wir junge talente unternehmen
und investitionen ins ausland dann
machen denn manche länder haben schon
alles umgesetzt was ich gerade
aufgezählt haben und wir verlieren jeden
tag geld zeit und nerven an eine
verwaltung die gezwungen ist weit unter
ihren möglichkeiten zu arbeiten wir
brauchen jetzt ergebnisse ein ergebnis
ist nicht dass ein rathaus 2022 anfängt
formulare als pdf auf seine webseite zu
stellen dass dich dann ausdrucken dorf
ein ergebnis ist ein komplett digitaler
verwaltungsprozess den ich online
schnell finde den ich verstehe den ich
bedienen kann und der mir zügig
ergebnisse liefert ohne dass ich das
haus verlassen das und nur das kann das
tier sein
die bundesregierung hat vor kurzem ihre
digital strategie vorgestellt sie
erkennt wir müssen ganz grundsätzliche
infrastruktur schaffen um zum ziel zu
kommen das alles fängt an mit der
sogenannten digitalen identität wir
müssen uns digital erstmal ausweisen
können um überhaupt loslegen zu können
das muss sicher sein und das muss
praktisch sein die gute nachricht ist
deutschland hat seit jahren eine sichere
lösung die auch praktisch sein könnte
das ist der personalausweis mit dem wir
uns theoretisch auch online ausweisen
können die schlechte nachricht wir haben
für den perso kaum und hauptsächlich zu
komplizierte anwendung die app für den
personalausweis heißt aus web ausweisapp
zweites ding klingt und bedient sich wie
die spam-mail eines nigerianischen
grinsen aber nicht wie die idee der
bundesrepublik deutschland wir brauchen
dringend eine nutzerfreundliche lösung
mit brauchbaren schnittstellen und
bezahlbaren
berechtigungszertifikate wir sprechen
heute über geld über den haushalt des
bundes für das kommende jahr wir wollen
60 millionen für die digitalität 'nen
ausgeben dass es ein wort neben der
digitalen identität ist auch wichtig wir
als nutzerinnen und nutzer müssen ein
benutzerfreundliches portal bekommen mit
den angeboten des status da werden sie
geholfen darum geht es 479 millionen
investiert ebenso erhöhen wir die mittel
für die register modernisierung deutlich
das heißt wir digitalisieren die daten
der verwaltung nur so kann ein digitaler
staat funktionieren die zahlen sind
trocken die das ziel es viel versprechen
die kunst liegt jetzt in der umsetzung
und dafür stellt diese haushalt geld zur
verfügung ein digitales deutschland ist
sowieso möglich lassen sie uns jetzt
möglichst schnell dorthin kommen haben
sie vielen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat der kollege florian oßner
für die cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin der herr
minister wissen ja liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen mit dem vorliegenden haushalt
wird eines deutlich
digitales und verkehr spielt eine völlig
untergeordnete rolle bei dieser ampel
regierung oder wie lässt sich sonst
erklären dass trotz
baukostensteigerungen und
mehrbelastungen durch die energiepreis
explosion nun nochmals in diesem bereich
eine milliarde euro eingespart wird seit
20 21 sogar schon 6 und 6 milliarden
euro liebe spd grüne und fdp ist es
wahrlich ein trauerspiel mit
wiederholung viele versprechen das
schüren hohe erwartungen und dann doch
fehlende umsetzung so verspielt man
jegliches politisches vertrauen
lag der verkehrsetat unter der von cdu
und csu geführten bundesregierung bei 41
milliarden euro solle jetzt von 36
milliarden in diesem jahr weiter auf 35
milliarden im nächsten jahr gekürzt
werden das ist angesichts der vielzahl
von herausforderungen die uns
bevorstehen und die bedeutung des
größten
investitionshaushalt des bundes absolut
unverantwortlich zumal ist im
bundeshaushalt eine vielzahl von
einsparmöglichkeiten gegeben hätte
insbesondere in der personalpolitik der
ampel wurde durch die bank in allen
ministerien ein wasserkopf an
versorgungsposten geschaffen die keine
wirklichen mehrwert versprechen und das
schlimme daran ist wichtige
zukunftsinvestitionen unterbleiben und
werden durch die gestiegenen baukosten
am ende sogar möglich das hat zur folge
dass unsere straßen schienen brücken und
schleusen immer weiter verfallen auch
die dringend notwendige digitalisierung
der verkehrswege völlig vergessen wo
bleibt hier der oft beschworene
fortschritt wie beamte kollegen der
sogenannten fortschritts koalition
[Applaus]
stichwort stichwort nur ein euro ticket
eingeschätzt der verkehrspolitische
sprecher thomas bareiß hatte ausführlich
besprochen und damit kann ich eine
minute ein sparen bevor es wieder
überfüllte züge gibt muss jetzt die
kapazität der bahn erst mehr ausgebaut
werden da müssen wir jetzt alle
finanziellen anstrengungen reinstecken
früher hätte man in solchen fällen von
der subventionspolitik mit der gießkanne
gesprochen die ampel ist hier inzwischen
einen schritt weiter und hat die
gießkanne durch ein vollautomatisiertes
bewässerungssysteme ersetzt welches
zügellos zügellos vor sich hin sprudelt
diese geldverschwendung auf kosten
zukünftiger generationen kann und darf
so nicht weitergehen
im bereich der straße ist der
mittelansatz stärken hier und allerdings
müssen auch hier natürlich die menschen
baukostensteigerungen berücksichtigt
werden so dass am ende sogar weniger
verbaut werden kann als ursprünglich
geplant damit seien projekte aus dem
bundesverkehrswegeplan massiv gefährdet
worauf sich aber alle viel vor ort
verlassen haben entlastungen von staus
und verkehrslärm dürfen am ende aber
nicht von ideologisch falschen
weichenstellungen abhängen
bei der schiller enttäuscht die rampe
deutlicher weise auf ganzer linie und
wird ihrem eigenen anspruch ihrem
eigenen anspruch nicht gerecht so werden
beispielsweise die mittel für die euro
für das europäische zugleich system um
80 millionen euro gekürzt für den
kombinierten verkehr sind diesen 15
millionen euro weniger das erklärte ziel
mehr verkehr von der straße auf die
schiene und auf das wasser zu verlagern
rückt damit in weite ferne und besonders
irritierend ist es für mich dass
ausgerechnet ein erklärter digital
minister bei der digitalisierung der
schiene gekürzt insbesondere wenn diese
ein sehr effizientes mittel wäre um dort
die taktzeiten zu verdichten auch hier
gehen anspruch und wirklichkeit
diametral auseinander
thema wasserstraßen ein totalausfall
denn anders ist nicht zu erklären dass
der verkehrsminister 32 august wittert
die binnenschifffahrt ist enorm wichtig
für unsere energieversorgung und
lieferketten zitat ende zeitgleich wird
aber bei keinem verkehrsträger mehr der
rotstift angesetzt wie bei der
wasserstraße nämlich 350 millionen euro
weniger als im jahr 2022 als heuer das
passt wirklich nicht zusammen herr
minister
und auch im bereich des digitalen bleibt
es bei vielen ankündigungen vom digital
bischöfe weiterhin jegliche spur die
groß angekündigte digitalstrategie ist
nur ein sammelsurium mit wenig belegten
haben punkten im haushalt investieren
für die verkehrsinfrastruktur bleibt
trotz anderweitiger versprechen
fehlanzeige uns haben vier begriffe
genannten kommen zum schluss frau
präsidentin verlässlichkeit vernunft
verantwortung und fortschritt das
prüfergebnis alle vier punkte nicht
erfüllt wir als cdu und csu stehen
bereit hier bei diesen punkten helfen
aber jetzt auf diesem abgelegenen
erwähnt ich kann man keine zukunft
herzliches vergelt's gott das zu hören
[Applaus]
für die spd fraktion hat nun die
kollegin anna kassels petersburg
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin herr
minister liebe kolleginnen der
demokratischen fraktionen sehr geehrte
damen und herren eine sache hat sich
auch in den unruhigen zeiten in denen
wir gerade leben nicht geändert
digitalisierung ist kein nice to have
das ist kein optionaler posten den man
irgendwann an gehen kann wenn mal zeit
und geld dafür da ist das ist bei vielen
themen der fall das ist mir klar aber
wir müssen jetzt in digitale
infrastruktur investieren damit wir den
kommenden jahren dinge wie die
digitalisierung der verwaltung oder der
schulen überhaupt flächendeckend
umsetzen können dazu benötigen wir jetzt
auch source technologien also
quelloffene technologien die so wenn
alle menschen die wollen auf den courts
zugreifen können mag das im ersten
moment so aussehen als würde die
software unsicher als würde es die
software unsicher machen genau das
gegenteil ist aber der fall nur wenn
sicherheitslücken gefunden werden und
mehr augen sehen mehr sicherheitslücken
können diese auch geschlossen werden und
machen die software so für uns alle
sicherer
weibezahl software wo man ihn nicht
kennen können solche lücken geheim
gehalten werden um beispielsweise den
ruf des unternehmens nicht zu schaden
oder wissentlich zugänge für
geheimdienste offen zu lassen wenn ich
meine terrassentür aber offen lasse kann
nicht nur meine katze dadurch schlüpfen
sondern auch alle anderen die wissen
dass sie offen ist wir machen uns
zusätzlich durch open source auch von
mark böschen software unternehmen
unabhängiger und auch das ist
bestandteil digitaler souveränität
open source bedeutet für uns als
fortschritts koalition public money
public out also da wo öffentliche gelder
hinfließen muss dieser code nicht nur
für sicherheitsüberprüfungen öffentlich
zugänglich sein sondern auch zur
weiterverwendung damit schaffen wir ein
innovatives umfeld in dem aus
bestehendem neue ideen impulse oder auch
start-ups entstehen können um uns als
gesellschaft weiterentwickeln zu können
müssen wir wissen teilen statt wie ein
drache auf dem schoß zu sitzen
wir müssen deswegen jetzt resilient
digitale strukturen schaffen die uns
ermöglichen kommende krisen und
bedrohungsszenarien zu meistern auch und
gerade in anbetracht von kraft
fachkräftemangel klimawandel und einer
älter werdenden gesellschaft deswegen
handeln wir als amt hält
und damit komme ich zum haushalt ich
habe ich sehr beispielsweise über den
ausbau der stellen beim
bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten gefreut
denn auch datenschutz und
informationsfreiheit sind kein nice to
have sie sind fundamentale bürgerrechte
ich bin auch froh dass sich das baby in
die netzpolitischen debatten einbringen
und mit uns gemeinsam
datenschutzkonforme lösung erarbeitet
datenschutz ist nämlich kein bremsklotz
in der digitalisierung sondern
elementarer bestandteil guter und
demokratischer digitalisierung
auch deshalb rät punch für open source
ist mit zehn millionen im haushalt
eingestellt das ist richtig stark in dem
aktuellen haushaltsentwurf fehlt mir das
zentrum für digitale souveränität und
das open data institute auch daten
institute genannt hier werden wir als
spd und in den haushaltsverhandlungen
dafür einsetzen dass diese noch mit
aufgenommen werden wir leben im jahr
2022 digitalisierung ist kein nice to
have wir als uncle sind mutig und packen
das deswegen an vielen dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat der kollege stefan seitel
und stefan seiler sitzt ja für den
südschleswigschen wählerverband der
einzige abgeordnete hier im bundestag
fehlt liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
liebe frau kollegin ich heute lieber
minister wissen wenn sie hier ein
schweres erbe beklagen denn schulden sie
es den menschen dort draußen aber auch
ganz ehrlich zu sagen dass wir uns wohl
in zeiten wehrenberg kassen befinden
selten sieht man dies so eindrücklich
wie im vorgelegten verkehrshaushalt für
das jahr 2023 die verkehrswende die
digitalisierung der schiene die
steigenden preise durch die inflation
sie stehen vor ganz großen aufgaben
dennoch sinken die investitionen des
bundes wie passt das zusammen die
bundesregierung sendet mit diesem
haushalt ein fatales signal an die
bürgerinnen und bürger die täglich mit
der maroden infrastruktur und
überlasteten bahnen konfrontiert sind
es ist an der zeit mehr und nicht
weniger geld in die hand zu nehmen herr
minister wissing dabei reicht es nicht
sich auf die überlasteten hauptstrecken
zwischen den metropolen zu beschränken
denn auch der ländliche raum muss an
eine verlässliche und belastbare
infrastruktur angeschlossen werden
dieses besonders im norden ein problem
hier mangelt es an guten und effizienten
angeboten für viele so hat im frühjahr
dieses jahres die deutsche bahn
angekündigt 890 millionen euro in die
schiene in schleswig holstein und
hamburg zu wissen investiert investieren
unmittelbar klingt das gut aber bei
genauerem hinsehen stellt man fest dass
der löwenanteil dieser summe der
anbindung des neuen firma welt tunnels
an die metropole hamburg dient in den
ländlichen raum meiner heimat an der
nordseeküste richtung flensburg fühlen
sich die menschen also zurecht
abgekoppelt und von zukunftsweisenden
mobilität auf der schiene ausgeklammert
so geht es sicher auch menschen in
anderen ländlichen teilen der republik
neben der infrastruktur ist aber auch
das personal und hier besonders der
nachwuchs ein gewaltiger problem erst
kürzlich beklagten mehrere eisenbahn
unternehmer aus dem hohen norden bei mir
den dramatischen mangel an
ausbildungsmöglichkeiten führt
zugführerin und zugführer wir können
doch nicht mehr und mehr schiene fordern
und am ende gibt es niemanden der die
züge fahren kann bahnlinien sind gerade
auf dem land wahre lebensader die
menschen blicken daher zu recht auf den
bund und wünschen sich dass dieser puls
weiter schlägt finden
der stefan seiler da er der einzige ist
hier im bundestag für den
südschleswigschen wählerverband hat er
keinen fraktionsstatus es gibt dann
immer fraktionsloser die allerdings auch
ein bisschen weniger redezeit haben
jetzt also der letzte hier am rednerpult
diesen einzelplan den für digitales und
verkehr das ist uwe schmidt für die spd
ein schluck trinken nach der comedy
einlage von kollegen florian oßner war
diese und trocknen muss also da war ja
schon richtig gut also herr minister
neuen kolleginnen und kollegen
der berechtigte veranschlagte hafen
beschäftigen in den norddeutschen
seehäfen hat einst wieder mal gezeigt
ohne den seeverkehr und ohne die
seehäfen geht es nicht 80 bis 90 prozent
des internationalen waffenhandels erfolg
über den seeweg sehr bedeutend für den
größten genuss industriestandort in
europa
die kuba-krise und erstaunen suezkanal
haben unsere wirtschaftliche
abhängigkeit vom seeverkehr abermals
verdeutlicht die weltweiten lieferketten
starten oder enden im jeweiligen hafen
der handelspartner steht dort die arbeit
still ruht im ganzen land der
warenverkehr deswegen haben wir im
koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart dass der bund endlich zu
seiner gemeinsam verantwortung mit den
ländern und kommunen für die notwendigen
hafen infrastrukturen stehen muss doch
ich habe immer noch das gefühl dass
sowohl unsere bundesverkehrsminister als
auch der bundesfinanzminister die
bedeutung der deutschen seehäfen und der
bundeswasserstraßen für die transport-
und logistikkette immer noch
unterschätzen haben die vorgänge
übrigens auch gemacht und die wollen sie
ein problem lösen die wir ohne sie gar
nicht gehabt hätten anders kann ich es
mir nicht erklären dass wir heute über
einen haushaltsentwurf sprechen in dem
der nasse bereich strukturell
unterfinanziert ist 350 millionen
weniger
350 millionen euro weniger mittel für
die bundeswasserstraßen das schon aus
nummer ich halte hat auch gesagt genau
ganz ruhig lachen jetzt kann ich halte
das für grob fahrlässig und ein
strategisches risiko für den erhalt der
bundeswasserstraßen aber wir gucken mal
die ko hat die haben wochenende noch ein
bisschen was beschlossen über diesen
umweltfreundlichen verkehrsträger findet
die beförderung von massengütern sowie
der transport von containern
insbesondere von gefährlichen gütern
statt dieser sommer hat uns doch
eindringlich gezeigt welche verheerenden
auswirkungen der klimawandel auch die
pegelstände der bundeswasserstraßen
zusammen stark bedeutet schlicht am
falschen ende sparen wir brauchen die
dringend notwendigen investitionen in
die infrastruktur wie die
hafenhinterlandanbindung und den ausbau
von kanälen und schleusen
aber es offensichtlich nicht nur eine
frage des geldes
überall ausgaben gäste und irgendwie
klingen die finanzmittel nicht so
richtig verbaut das zieht sich durch wie
ein roter faden in diesem etat muss man
auch mal feststellen die steuerung und
umsetzung der bauvorhaben des bundes
sind massives problem
herr minister da müssen sie jetzt mal
ran weil die letzten zwölf jahre haben
offensichtlich spuren in dem
verkehrsministerium hinterlassen
aber jetzt tragen sie die verantwortung
für die laden endlich in schwung ich
glaube da an solchen ansatz dass sie das
können haben sie damit neun euro ticket
bereits gezeigt die unterstützung der
spd fraktion haben sie in dem fall und
tun sie mir den gefallen sich an sie die
bord arbeitsplätze von seeleuten in der
deutschen hochseefischerei und küsten
und auf küstenfischerei fahrzeugen über
die schifffahrt förderung was ja leider
in der schiffs besetzungs verordnung
nach hinten losgehen hier waren die
beschäftigten auf die konkrete umsetzung
das ist haushaltsgesetz setzen sie das
betonen die aufgaben im verkehrsbereich
sind riesig einfach an die sicherung der
europäischen
das fähigkeit der deutschen see der bund
muss ein hohes interesse an der
leistungsfähigkeit der seeschifffahrt
einer deutschen seehäfen unter beweis
stellen dazu gehört dass sie sich für
die harmonisierung der
wettbewerbsbedingungen auf europäischer
ebene einsetzen stichwort
gruppenfreistellungsverordnung wir
werden sie den parlamentarischen
haushaltsberatung begleiten und sie
daran erinnern ich freue mich darauf
danke
das sagte schmidt zum abschluss hier
erste lesung dieses einzelplan ist 12
digitales und verkehr ja und volker
wissing hat es zu beginn dieser beratung
gesagt dass neun euro ticket natürlich
nach wie vor in jedermann und jederfrau
hunde hier die nachfolge wird ja gesucht
die koalition hat sich darauf
verständigt dass es seine nachfolge
geben soll der bund würde 15 milliarden
euro zuschießen allerdings müssten die
länder das auch machen und die
bundesländer haben auch schon angemeldet
das jedoch mit ihr reden wollen nicht
nur was das neuen euro ticket und die
finanzierung anbelangt da müssten sogar
mit reden sondern auch was das
entlastungspaket insgesamt anbelangt
also eine bund länder runde steht da ins
haus und da soll dann auch über die
nachfolge des neuen euro tickets
behandelt werden gesprochen